[Music]
foreign
phantom we're rolling i know can we get
your game face on please
this is it's always on you guys benton's
in a wild move no i'm not you said it
every day okay we're gonna start
tallying them down
benton showed up today speaking cockney
that's not wild literally that's exotic
i was brushing my hair and i just hear
it
[Music]
i think that's fine it happened slapped
you're lucky i was on the roof like
chim-chimney
it's like lemony snicket has arrived
sweeney todd and when i do that i have
to do a kegel
yeah it has to come from in here that's
not where vaginas are i know but that's
where the voice has to come from
hello right and the worst part is in
london trolley really
honestly can you
not good ain't it gorgeous yeah you're
doing quite well
lovely day isn't it from now on if we
ever fight
give a fuck can we do it in that accent
yeah i love it are you fucking dense are
you stupid
scrubby scruffy fuck off honestly you've
gone west
that's my favorite you've gone waste
what does that mean
i guess it means you're going i don't
really know but i don't know which means
you've gone to california which means
you've gone crazy yeah you've got well
is that west of london
uh yeah okay we're west i wish i could
do an australian accent
because they're a lot you know they
don't do oh dude it's hard to do both in
the same
day the same day right so
what's uh australian is it's like um
hello mate
well you sound like the worm from the
labyrinth you know that little worm
i love that me too oh it's so cute it's
very
hello it's all you kane are you cute
keen that means like horny right are you
keen oh
i thought okay i am yeah
this music is wonderful no i can't
wonderful yeah
there's no there's no o's right they're
all r's or there's no r's there's only
o's
god this podcast has gone in a weird
direction brand wise i just want to
reach out to other other people
so that's what i'm dealing with you guys
and you can't do any accident without
being racist so that's the only one you
can really get away with
can you be racist okay right or not
racist but like brood that's rude
you can't do asian accents let's not
conflate racist and rude please
because if they start to become the same
thing i'm getting cancelled
i know you're allowed to be rude okay
i'm not letting that be taken
being british is like being american
it's just like rude
but you can't do like asian accents oh
that's very that's not nice i've dated
some english guys it's a fucking hot
accent
australian i don't know it's a little
twangy
you know wasn't australia big prison
yeah well no it was where they sent
uh yeah people i don't know can you
please
can we can we okay here we go you maybe
look things up before you just throw
them out on the podcast i thought you
knew everything
can you can you please do some research
yes it was uh
prisoners that were sent to australia
right okay
that's way hotter way hotter than
british doctors
he just throws things out he's like so
what's dna can you explain what a double
helix is whitney i'm trying to join a
cult why are you
oh good segue we are talking about cults
today but not yet
first we're going to talk about my cult
of comedy
which is going on the road yeah san fran
san francisco we added a show
are you excited to go to san francisco
yeah because i know we're not too weird
for san francisco
no no possible way y'all are wild we're
gonna be at the midway
not sure what that is uh on november 7th
2020 san francisco it's going to be
outside it's going to be distanced
please don't make out with strangers or
have threesomes or orgies and give each
other covid you guys i don't want to be
the coveted comedian it's a very sand
friend thing to do
they'll be in harnesses and horsemen san
francisco hair i got my pink hair
yeah i could maybe be a lesbian we got
to get you some nipple clamps and you'll
be ready to go
san francisco gals come to the show try
to turn me
now that my hair is something a lot of
women are like you're gay fyi
do you think i am nope that's not how
being gay works oh if it did though
you'd be there
but a lot of i'm getting a lot of dms
from women that are like by the way
you're gay
that's rude you can't tell people that i
don't think you can't be like you're gay
and i'm so co-dependent i'm like you're
probably right
you've never thought i was gay no you've
never been like she's probably gay
never or like that's she's got it's
going to any day now the shoes no drones
deserve one many tequilas no
no no okay fine why would i think i just
tried to come out to you
you shut me down you don't come out by
going have you ever maybe sorta kind of
thought that i was like it's not a safe
space did you ever think i was
all right couple announcements i'd like
to make benson you need to pull it
together
when it comes to my instagram because i
decided
that i was gonna not look at my feed so
much
because i feel like it's just it's not
healthy it's a it's an unhealthy
addiction
i did mute some people if you're on a
private plane and if you're doing yoga
on a rock
and if you're face tuning yourself i'm
muting you it's called self-care
still love you forgive you but i'm just
not
i don't even see that shit you know what
i mean i got enough i got enough
nasty inner inner monologue thoughts but
i was like okay i'm not gonna look i'm
not gonna obsess over instagram i'm not
gonna look at the news i also did like a
little news detox
and then i was like you know we had that
covet-tested comedy show we all got
tested we were all negative
and we did the comedy show and
afterwards uh esther and annie they
taught
me the wet ass pussy dance there's some
hoes in this house
and we did it and we're like humping the
floor it was like funny and i couldn't
get it right it was just kind of this
funny video
and so i don't have something to post
for the day post it
it's hilarious let's be honest i do have
a little cake back there
i've been working out little debbie
snacks
hey cupcakes or cakes guys there's a
moon pie back there right now
there's like there's a little angel food
cake
in the cheeks right now like i've got a
little yeah you have a butt for sure
for sure for sure all of a sudden all
that biking and
i don't know all that fetal position and
terror it's really worked out
i tried to get up from off the floor
those squats
um so i post it and i'm like okay great
and i go back to checking in on it like
maybe an hour later and i'm scrolling
it's 9 11. it's the anniversary of the
twin towers
being hit by a plane and i have chosen
to post
my ass cake jiggling
so were you also avoiding calendars when
you were i just had to
talk i'm not gonna look at my phone
today i'm so healthy
i'm taking a detox break look at me
rewiring my brain
and i go and i scroll and it's like
never forget never forget never forget
and then just my
pussy shaking humping the floor
i mean can you i love when i make a
mistake
girl no next time no i refuse to support
celebrities until i am one
okay and i i just love the thought of
like you making a mistake and going like
okay um
it's because i was detoxing guys i was i
know
it's just because i wasn't i wasn't like
there i was like reconnecting with
myself oh it was the anniversary of 9
11.
i would not have posted myself doing the
wet ass pussy dance that would have not
been my first
choice happens every night i would have
posted a black square
let's be honest that's what really makes
lasting you would have took
responsibility it is my fault
i would have posted myself singing
imagine
and then i did it oh i have a terrible
joke never mind and then i did it
you're allowed to say terrible things on
youtube uh if you would've let the
bodies hit the floor
what's that you don't know the song that
the body to the floor the body is at the
floor
that the body is said yes i do know that
that have been horrible but hilarious oh
yeah oh my god that's so much
i know i said that budget is dark and
this is why i love you
we're allowed to say shit like that on
this podcast you guys i'm not letting
jokes get cancelled
i'm not letting this the alt left take
away
sick jokes yeah the alt left won't take
jokes and the alt right won't
take rights we're stopping it all here
uh
and then i did it again uh whitney did
it again
i i well my hair my pink hair which
everybody knows
uh we've heard about it have you heard
about it we've seen it we've heard about
it secret i know i don't want to talk
about it much i'm very shy
it's starting to fade right and i was
like oh i need to go to a different
color because pink it is starting to get
a little bit crazy
and i'm not getting as many matches on
raya as i used to
um and so i was like why don't i dye it
a different color
this pandemic doesn't seem to be going
away any time soon and i posted like you
guys what should i what should i post
which i how should i dye my hair now
what color should i do next just the
most shallow
vapid post on the planet post it but i'm
detoxing
i'm not obsessed with social media i'm
not on so i'm not that's why you're
posting i'm not scrolling so i'm just
gonna post it and get out of there
i'm a healthy person i'm gonna post the
photo then go for a walk i'm gonna go
read a book
he said i am the party i'm gonna show up
and leave i'm gonna show up
and leave and then i go back to check
see how the post is doing
ruth bader ginsburg has crossed over
she has passed it's like rest in peace
recipes recipes recipes rest in peace
people sobbing then i'm like you guys
what color hair should i now
you just try to be relatable my roots
are also dead guys
i didn't know a true icon legend star
and hero has passed on and you're like
you think purple's fun you guys blew her
pink
i did not know she had died so for all
of you that think that i'm an
insensitive
cunt as you would say i like that the
excuses i didn't know she died so
i mean had i known and i know and i
would have posted this three hours later
i would have gave a break i'm not tacky
you're like how long is the funeral
i need to talk about my eye makeup
that's so sad anyway so you guys if
you've been thinking that i'm complete
like a total sociopath based on the fact
that i've been
posting really shallow posts on um
her during horrific tragedies then
you've been listening to the podcast
and we want to thank you and i'm so
sorry um
i want to talk about the nexium calls
wait there's some bigger news that you
skipped over oh sorry well hillary duff
is here first of all hillary duff is on
the show today so we need to
plow through this we got hillary duff
i know which is shocking it's a big deal
why is it shocking because she didn't
ever do podcasts
she never does podcasts and the amount
of celebrities that wanted to come
listen to her do this podcast so weird
how exciting she's going to be because
celebrities don't hear about nobody but
themselves
well all my famous friends were like can
i come and meet hillary i'm like i don't
know
what pull yourself together can i pray
at her altar yeah well here's the thing
i think i'm
see i really don't want to have to admit
this but i i didn't
i wasn't i think i'm just older so i i
like i love hillary i know her like
we're friends
i met her without having had her show be
like my religion i was in my so-called
life kind of bitch
that was my show growing up if i saw
claire danes i would just
jump off a building you know but shannon
doherty i'm 902 no that was my shit
shannon dougherty dm to me on instagram
once and i like
literally i had um my heart took a shit
in my chest like i lost my mind
i was dming with alanis morissette the
other day couldn't breathe
that's i mean i think he may breathe
started doing lamaze
like my nipples got hard it was wild but
like hillary duff i love her and we
became friends in a very organic way
and i didn't realize that she was like
such a
that she was like a religion for people
yeah because well you grew up
with her kind of if you're around that
you did yeah i'm old it's rude
but also i'm curious benton wears a
shirt with hilary duff on it
i do benton will show up with
celebrities on his shirt which is so
weird because half those celebrities are
like my friends that's i'm always like
oh i need to call her back
it always reminds me i think that's so
weird for me because like i just
know all these celebrities so many
celebrity friends no that's not true
uh it's more like i mean this is just
what i do
i don't know maybe yeah i do have i have
two hillary duff shirts not friends with
like lady gaga
no i'm not friends with music people
keep this hair up and we'll get there
keep plagiarizing her vibe but
you wear a hillary duff shirt almost all
the time and i gotta say i was worried
you were gonna wear it when she came and
i was like what if he shows up in his
hillary duff shirt is she gonna call the
player i'm not a psychopath
i would have been sitting in the hallway
listening to the interview in a hillary
duff shirt
like hi like how insane i mean i don't
know i don't put anything past you at
this point benton
um how adorable is she i mean she can
you believe in real life
yeah it's it's actually she is an angel
she's true
i am in 12 12-step programs and read
self-help books
to be like her loved by all
loved by all loved be loved but she's
just like she's great anyway so the
interview is great it's coming up i
didn't want to
ruin her brand her publicist did not
know she was doing this interview
but you should listen she never does
podcast she never i mean you only really
get to hear her talk she talked about
her placenta about like the
like the work she's doing the shows
she's on but you don't get to hear her
just
talk and like she's a mystery so she's
an enigma
she's like found out about that i didn't
i did ask about lizzie mcguire and
what's going on the reboot she's very
like she knows how to not
say what she shouldn't say but i think i
think she definitely said a couple
things that she's never said
she's a pro she's a professional all
right i
um so she's coming up uh i do need to
talk about this
show but i'm gonna talk about david
blaine why flying over arizona
with balloons david blaine okay do you
even know who david blaine is
yeah he's the one that doesn't wear
eyeliner
he's the less glamorous magician yeah
he's the sloppy magician
magician stunt man he's a snake he's the
one that doesn't bother to put on makeup
yeah no when i was growing up david
blaine like i was trying to fuck david
blaine he was your hillary though
and yeah he was my hillary clinton you
were trying to let him out of your house
he was
like a god on mtv he was huge and he
would do these like sleight of hand he
would do these stunts he would
sit in ice boxes like before joe rogan
did it before it was like what every
like mma fighter and podcast guy did
it's so funny because you can look on
any anyone that joe rogan follows is
sitting in a box of ice all day every
day and but that was like
yeah really david blaine just has bad
knees it's just for his swelling
and um he would just like do this wild
shit
and it's just it's weird because that
stunt happened and i don't
did he make it like it was it's just so
weird how
media has shifted and it doesn't seem
like
i mean he flew away into the sky and
nobody cares yeah they're like post a
makeup tutorial
like it's just 10 years ago that would
have been the biggest thing ever
he floated away on rainbow colored
balloon that's every gay teen in
arizona's dream to leave their own
rainbow colored balloons
the fact they weren't shot out of the
sky is progress honestly
it's just it just was interesting to me
that this guy risked his life and we're
all like
but do you contour i mean people on
social media have new faces every other
week so like that's not that impressive
wait you still have the same face yeah
do you have a new butt you have button
plants do you have
get a little cheek failure there's
screaming things like it's just so weird
what people care about and what people
don't but can you do a choreographed
dance for 15 seconds
on the ground i know that you're flying
away and doing something absolutely
impossible but can you do lazy
cheerleading
in baggy tie-dye yeah he had to get like
all these certifications like log all
these hours skydiving
before i can people are like whatever
literally nobody gave a shit
um and then i mean i did love him on joe
rogan
he also like swallows frogs and you know
he'll like swallow a frog and puke it
back up meanwhile like
people like yeah we just ate nine tide
pods bitch it's not that impressive yeah
i've seen a lizard great
it's amazing how like tick tock and
reels and instagram and stuff has made
actual magicians like not that
impressive
yeah they're just like whatever we'll
edit that together cool
like i just drank an entire carton of
milk upside down
there's some girl just showing her
acrylics with four million views
can you do gels yeah that's all people
really care about
this is so funny that was fun it's this
is not news
this is this is a segment we like to
call should have been bigger news
this is the thing that we had to call
stop stop doing that
it should have been called just learn
the wap dance stay on the ground
um nexium what are you gonna let me talk
about this now we can talk about it
right now
i'm obsessed with this so if you guys
have not watched
this documentary i don't i don't know i
don't know what to tell you
um turns out you're not who i thought
you were we you've changed
it's on hbo max or i don't understand
what's hbo hp max
it's the new hbo is it hbo go no that's
gone hbo hbo mac put to keep up hbo no
go
hbo mac hbo it's their new streaming
service
where they got the good show fuck is my
password how many times a day do i ask
you for my hbo password
just the hbo one or is the hbo pap it's
the hbo password and the hbo max
password
all your passwords are the same password
so it really i mean there's like a whole
list of them but they're all just the
same fuck
what what's the max what does max mean
climax hbo climax
oh that's a good one is that the sex one
i'd watch that hbo climax
that's just your special on a loop
no i was not climaxing that year at all
frankly which is a lot of what i talked
about in the special
so i'm obsessed with this call uh the
nexium called
nexium nexium n-x-i-v-u-m no valve named
my acid reflux medicine
is it real yeah so i was i was in deep i
was like let me know more about this
you've changed my life they all had acid
reflux from deep throating that cult
leader's dick
right now all right so i want to really
slow down and talk about this cult
because i
i need to zoom out as we say in the biz
zoom out
zoom out i need to understand why every
cult leader
is such a fucking doofus
should i mean they're all first of all
they're all like short
uh look guys that look like legumes
oh have you noticed like they always
look insane there have been lots of
cults like the bikram yoga guy cult
that happened recently and yeah um he
was the guy that looked like the
floating ball in big trouble in little
china
you can't be half bald with a ponytail
don't follow that person why they can't
make decisions
like why does every cult leader look
like jabba the hutt
it's like wild how they're able to you
know what i think it is
women think they're non-threatening oh
yeah and that's how they get them
don't you think which is interesting
because if an ugly person hits on you at
a bar they're the most threatening
so true but like if they have if they
keep saying the word authenticity
even though they look like the baby in
total recall they can start a call
yeah this guy looks like tommy pickles
like if you're like what the hell
there's something going on you guys we
don't talk about short guys enough dude
i'm telling you
stalin five five vladimir putin
five seven motherfucker wears wedges
yeah
this is a known fact okay there's
something there
i think short guys know they have to
overcompensate by manipulating how else
are they going to get laid
so these short guys these are the ones
you got to watch the ones with the low
ponytail
in the back definitely a low post these
are the ones you got
to watch anymore with a low ponytail you
should watch in general because they're
either going to be handling
snakes somewhere or like
raising tigers like don't don't fuck
with those people but they need to find
ways to have power they can't physically
conquer our bodies so they have to
conquer our minds like this guy that ran
the nexium called
keith renier ranier says his name
dude everything he says was a hutter
nonsense
you hear him talking to these girls and
he's like well pain and suffering
those are two completely different
things and they're like yeah
that was my senior quote actually that's
nothing
that's a nonsense nothing he's insane he
would be like
so in order for creativity to be happen
authenticity has to be congruent and
they'd be like oh
yeah you have to rearrange the things
you think could happen for what will
and you're like i don't know what are
your rules that's what i will say for
everybody clowning on the women
that were beguiled by that and
hypnotized we've all done that
we've all we all did this like in high
school or college where
some idiot was just using big words in
an order you had never heard before
and making eye contact with you and you
bought it you know and you're like yeah
that sounds
genius like it's like watching a david
lynch movie like
you don't know what it means nobody
knows what it means but no one wants to
seem stupid so they all just
yeah they know what it means because
they assume everyone else knows what it
means it's like this weird like
mass hypnosis i mean the big thing in
this documentary the big selling point
is he was in the guinness book of world
records i was like yes that was the
person with the longest fingernail but
you don't take hygiene advice from them
do you
people they're like he has the highest
iq between what the woman who can jump
the highest and the man who's a lizard
like what does that mean
that's who it's so stupid the actual
smartest in the world isn't running
around like doing photo shoots for the
guinness book of world records yeah
they're not they don't have time they're
they're developing vaccines dumbass well
he created a new math don't forget
okay that was my favorite part of the
documentary me too when the guy goes
he created new mathematics like wait
first oh no he said it remember the guy
asked him a question at the kitchen
table he goes
well i've actually invented this this
new math and he was like awesome
dude no you didn't the only person i
actually think would be cool is someone
that got rid of the old math
i i didn't like the first math i don't
want another math to have to learn
first of all why what were you trying to
figure out
how unemployed are you that you were
like just sitting around inventing a new
map
second of all no you didn't
no you fucking did it no one could
corroborate that claim
because if you invented it no one else
knows it so no one else can check your
math
to make sure it's real man that's some
nerd shit that's like that's like i
learned klingon no you didn't
i just like like no no you like
also was the math that we had not
working not for him
he was like two plus two was four he's
like i don't see i just i don't i think
we need to well honestly there's two too
so now there's four this like you're
just making shit up these people are
like
that is amazing here's what i'll say
because
the people that were so beguiled by him
and then fell for it i
i do think we don't talk enough about
how
cults are good because they keep crazy
people
off the streets don't you think like
the this girl walks in and he's like he
says to her al that alice and matt girl
that crazy she's in insane i'm kind of
obsessed with her though but he goes um
uh so why do you why do you like art and
she just starts crying
yeah i was like okay this girl needs to
be
in an attic in albany away from the rest
of us this bitch because if she was not
she would be
maskless in a trader joe's yelling at
staff
spitting in their faces like these are
all would-be karens
she's wildly delusional too wild also
also if i may defend them also i blame
the dads
this is a lot of girls that did not get
eye contact or easy bake ovens or lu
that their dad's dropped the ball
good parenting does not like her dad
dropped her
she's fucked okay when she went in there
and she was like guys my life is perfect
i'm rich i'm famous i have everything
aren't you an extra in smallville like
aren't you a background actress i know i
was like wait a second hold on what's
happening
but also this is kind of like hard to
explain but everything was also on
camera
so my you have to understand when a
documentary is being made everyone knows
they're on camera
and they're also all kind of performing
so everyone's like
i used to be an actress it's like no
you're still an actress you're recording
your cult life like you're acting you're
on a reality show
they record everything they're like we
just need to be authentic well why are
you
on camera all the time they're all on
camera wearing like
silk scarves no but they're all like i
just want to
be able to find validation without uh
needing anything from anyone it's like
well then why do you have seven cameras
around you and why do you have to film
everything you do it's truly just a room
of like 50 people
talking about what they're gonna do in
the future so they never do anything
nothing they just sit in a house and be
like
so we're gonna eventually come to a
place where we win when sir when we
gonna get there
so funny at least scientologists lie at
least they're like we built some schools
dude scientology it gave me a whole new
respect for scientology at least
scientology put some fucking
effort into their religion dude there
were aliens there's like
satans and levels and they record they
they're they at least they have
powerpoints
award shows they at least wrote like a
lord of the rings type
backstory yeah this was just like
like um this guy just whispers nonsense
every time every time
words over and over again dude the
volleyball here's what's so funny about
the volleyball i have a hot take on the
volleyball
for those of you not that haven't seen
it yet because you can't figure out your
fucking hbo max password um
it's he makes it play volleyball every
night from midnight to like three in the
morning or something
and everyone's like the volleyball what
is what only in fucking hollywood
would the weirdest thing about a sex
cult be the fact that they're playing
volleyball
it was like put this vault like the sex
cult the branding everyone's like oh
that's kind of normal that's what we do
this is hollywood this is like every
time we go on an audition we do those
things
volleyball it's such so elitist that
people think volleyball is weird because
i lived in virginia we love volleyball
is we played it all the time it's very
fun
i was on the volleyball team the reason
that hollywood people and like
twitter elite are so confounded by the
volleyball is because it's just a middle
america sport
it's not if it was like yoga or it was
isolating
what it was ice skating if it was like
soul cycle or spinning or pilates they'd
be like wait this cult is genius yeah
all things that aren't sports
like because it was called like the
volleyball barn or something and
everyone's like
ew that looks poor does like nobody
wonder what this man is doing
all day that he only made up at midnight
do you ever notice we never see him in
the daytime he sleeps all day the bikram
guy was like that too well i
sleep all day wait am i a cult leader
probably that's very
common with podcasts nowadays i do need
two naps a day benton knows this
i just don't understand what he's doing
and no one cares total sense to me
it's a sex cult he's trying to normalize
knee pads everybody's like he's wearing
knee pads
i fucking hated that shit every time he
had knee pads on i was like what is he
doing he's just wearing them in
just everywhere why did that bother you
so much because i don't
are grown unders looking at this man in
knee pads being like tell me more papa
i have a question though what they had
to give collateral they had to give
naked photos of themselves obviously
this guy was like getting off on
them sending the naked photos i have a
hot take what's so wrong with with porn
oh um i don't know just watch legal real
porn why would you want to
these girls they weren't doing what i'm
saying i mean i have a question
what kind of um sex freaks like these
people are
are also wearing tiny shiny scarves
i love that the worst the fashion is the
part you hate the most i just depict one
of the someone
to start pulling on those and then just
to never stop like that's what it looks
like it looks like i
hate that and and the body chains
i didn't see the body chains yet yeah
allison no they say that you know
allison wears the body changes
are cute what does she christina in the
90s like that's how you're gonna promote
your love
sexy i know they're cheesy but they are
sexy like when i
i a guy that i'm kind of dating
i looked at the people that he follows
and i went to
some i was like doing a little instagram
stock and then i saw
that what a girl had on a body chain and
i was like that fucking bitch that's
cheating
wearing a body chain is cheating no
that's some nerd shit no that's like
your princess leia okay that's
we're going on it we're going on a
tangent guys fall for that shit
body chains chokers guys love that shit
body chain yes i'm telling you no no no
excuse me it's a hot look male species
do you like body changes
they're trashy but they're hot i'm just
telling i'm not
i'm talking over we're gonna get the
answer it's like vanilla perfume
oh i have that on a barrel it's fish in
a barrel body chains
uh i want to answer do you like body
chains
don't do anything great chris dave
is fired
who chokers chokers yeah yeah yeah
chokers are hot
well there isn't crisp girls that wear
chokers suck dick better or something
what isn't that a pew research study the
choker sucked dick better isn't there
something about girls that wear chokers
suck better dick or something
because that's how they have to make
money to survive or why i don't know
maybe their throats are tighter
i know because of the choker i don't
know i heard this
one time i need to bring a doctor back
on because something's happened
what are you what's going on are you
starting a cult right now
are you making a new math as we speak
okay so here's what i'll say one time i
i ordered this really cute choker off of
the
interweb and it had like a circle right
here and then a bunch of people started
dming me like oh yeah i saw your choker
like
wanna fuck and i was like oh did i
accidentally stumble into like uh
some subliminal sex messaging it's the
same with my tattoo i have a
tattoo right here that is a on my wrist
that's a safety pin
and people will always uh message me and
be like oh you have the safety pin like
it's some
people are men people it's women too
there's some weird cult about safety
pins that i got this and i didn't know i
had joined it by accident i mean there's
a lot
with with i think when you wear a choker
it sends a message
that you're like down to fuck everything
that's remember when those rubber
bracelets were a thing in the 90s and
they were like this one means you do
anal and you're like no it's just i got
it
on topic like no i got it out of a
cracker or like handkerchiefs like well
this color means we're not in prison
what are you talking about can you stop
yeah
i just i'm just blowing mine it's a
handkerchief
you fucking freak i love it when benjen
snaps
it's just crazy i love that everything
is not sexual i love that benton the
thing he hates the most about
the um nexium cult is that the scarves
are
cheap he's like they are really cheap
but everything was like
the fact that people were falling for
this i'm watching it
and it's truly everything takes place in
like
a hilton honors hotel like someone's
living room
everything is in like a shitty
one-bedroom apartment he's always like
the the cult leader is always like
waxing poetic on a like a
ikea mahogany couch that's just like
covered in like clam chowder and cum
it's like
it's so obvious this is clam chowder and
gum i don't know
damn what about
[Laughter]
like why is he you're just making me
laugh because you're so excited
uh the fact that this motherfucker like
pull up in a ford fiesta and everyone's
like this is our leader
like kissing his feet i know like dude
he's in a fucking pt cruiser like
staying at the doubletree like i
at least the uh oh show guy had like
bentley's seriously if i'm gonna join a
cult i want a little pomp and
circumstance i want
i want an eyes wide shut sex party with
masks and beaks and capes and
yeah we better live on a compound i want
a gala
a gala a gala okay uh she wants a gala
guys
can we a gayla we've just skipped over
the fact in in this documentary they
sprinkled in the fact that they cured
tourettes
like we're fully just like we cured
tourette's anyways we're going on a walk
at three you're like no no we have to go
back but you guys do have to watch this
they here's the thing the first if i was
22 before
12 step program and you had no friends i
this called i would have been in that
call
hundo percent hundo hundo that's how we
know
i absolutely would have felt they had
some good they make some good points
i'm not gonna lie and then they it does
seem like they cure directly no it
doesn't
they just it's a commercial where they
just show someone who's now not
having a moment they just cut out the
torrent pretty convincing i actually i
i if if that call can help me stop
interrupting people in the podcast i'll
do it i will suck that guy's dick to
stop getting comments that i'm
interrupted
not what tourette's is and also
literally they're just like we've cured
tourettes anyways guys we have to sell
five more packets to eight more clients
you're like no no
how come there's no doctors here there's
nobody wants this secret
i mean it is a pyramid scheme but here's
the other thing everyone's like
oh my god it was like all these girls
got together and they
branded they all got the same brand and
it was
and they didn't eat it's like you mean a
sorority yeah right
we've all done that like by the way it's
not that different
from uh spring break 97 like honestly
i did ex the same exact thing except it
was in panama city florida
and it wasn't a brand it was a dolphin
tattoo on the back of my neck
that's a fact do you know how many
infinity symbols and tiny stars i've
covered up in my makeup career
yes i'm just saying like girls and
getting together and they branded each
other like
every group of girls has done that at
lake havasu
on spring break it was just like a
little chinese symbol that said breathe
yeah the only thing's gonna last forever
is that shitty tattoo it was also
sorry i mean this is fucked up that i'm
laughing about it but they were like
i got branded and i thought it was a
mountain with three lines through it and
then i turned sideways and it was his
initials like
maybe before you get a tattoo look at it
from every angle
first of all can we talk about that too
how they're just naked in a van
blindfold and they're like
okay guys so it's gonna represent the
elements why are you guys wicked now
what happened
when did the elements come into play it
was just so funny that there she was
like
and then i looked at it sideways like
first of all how did you look at it
sideways you have to
if you're gonna get a tattoo as a woman
near your pussy look at it from the
angle that the person going down on you
is gonna
look from every angle because the
tattoo's not for you she's like this way
it's alice and mac i was like first of
all they didn't even look like oh it was
allison mack and then you turned it and
it was keith raniere's yeah but i'm just
thinking like how come all of you agreed
to getting the element's tattoo on you
anyway it has nothing to do with
anything
tattoo sucked before you found out it
was some random
creepy leprechaun's name and then him
and then him being like well was i
involved because i gave them the
equipment to brand people is that why
you think i was involved who are you
trying to trick
dude i it also makes me laugh that this
motherfucker like
thought he was gonna get away with this
like like i'm gonna put
20 girls in a house
what could go wrong like that's a
brothel the fact that he was so
surprised that 20 girls couldn't keep
a secret like are we known for our
ability to keep secrets
is this like are we known and by the way
i'm gonna starve them they're not gonna
be able to eat like are we
known for being so amicable when we're
hungry
yeah right like you're gonna get a bunch
of girls together
make them hangry and let them just
gossip about you all day like what do
you think is gonna happen homie
and then the relationship where they all
have to like ask for everything like may
i eat
may i do this yeah let's let's try to
throw you in that real quick
no this is what it was explain what it
was thank you they did um
this thing where uh they the part of the
dom
relationship uh was that in or
your master would have to let you eat
would have to let you do everything you
go to bed
to eat all that stuff it's basically
like a like a woot band
in person it's basically like a real
live uh
what are those things that you step
thing a fitbit it's like a it was like a
real life fitbit like can i have a
hundred calories can i have this oh yeah
yeah i mean that's having a weight coach
well and you know episode four that girl
the one who won't be shown
is like this could have happened to
anyone i'm like no it couldn't have no
i the whole i watched the entire
documentary being like if this was
whitney
she would never they would be like you
have to leave oh yeah i love the idea of
you bringing it i really wish you would
go join
i don't think i could be in a call is
this still going on i'd get so bored
uh no the trial is happening now and
also you know that this was all
funded they had a tremendous amount of
money from the girls uh
dad started seagrams yeah one of the
bronfmans
put 150 million dollars in this cult and
i was like oh my god i couldn't believe
she did that
really her dad got rich getting people
drunk what did you what kind of like
ethical
paragon of ethics did you think this was
coming from they're like how could this
girl do this with a father that got
rich getting people drunk so they could
drive and die
like i mean it's like her father was a
piece of shit too
that's the z what if a arrow just hit me
in the neck
because i just attacked a bronze man
they couldn't afford arrows so don't you
worry
oh the bronfman's could i think that i
think i should not be coming after uh
liquor empires that's probably a bad
idea who gives a shit
is this one still going on this thing is
called no it's counting no i mean the
liquor empire has to all right of course
yes
are you kidding my family alone has kept
them in business
yes i was breastfed sea grumps i know
this i've been in this cult
i mean yeah her dad started a cult too
it's called alcoholics anonymous
they come from cults you guys really
have to watch this documentary because
it's
insane so good um all right we've got to
stop uh
hillary duff i love her so much what a
treat what a delight
it's a banger like subscribe
we're going to start doing giveaways
guys like subscribe comment
this reminds me what of you talking
about how celebrities froze their
instagram and then you being like like
subscribe
follow you guys we need to talk about
that sorry
i forgot to bring this up the instagram
freeze did you guys see the celebrities
froze their instagram quote unquote to
quote stop hate because of facebook
what the fuck is going on why are
celebrities so out of touch they're like
we're gonna take a day off lecturing you
guys about causes we know nothing about
in order to promote another cause we
know absolutely nothing about
you're like great i would love a day
without you trying to relate to me by
eating taco bell
like do you know why i mean talk about
it though i can afford okay it's not a
fun trend
i would love to have a day off from you
guys
lecturing me about who to vote like
please like when they're like
we're gonna boycott instagram for a day
everyone's like bitch i muted you years
ago when you were posting photos of
yourself with politicians
yeah okay we i love the people like the
celebrities
that are freezing their instagram
they're like
we're doing this because it's it's
facebook is pro-trump
and this is spreading hate about
pro-trump bitch the reason trump got
elected is because
you wouldn't stop posting selfies of
yourself with hillary
that's why he won right also question
don't most of you have shows on facebook
watch
yeah didn't they just drop by a
billboard with you on it they're like
you guys
i'm boycotting facebook also watch my
new show on facebook watch
yeah next month they'll come back
because we have a we have a good episode
the fact that celebrities thought that
they were muting their instagram
and like boycotting instagram for a day
dumbasses you realize that
usually your posts show up a day or two
days later anyway because of the
algorithm so you weren't even boycotting
the day you thought you were boycotting
yeah also do you think i've seen
all your photos like i don't look at
anybody else's page also do you think
that like
we're all gonna fall apart if you don't
post a photo of yourself on a red carpet
and be like i love miss wearing dresses
miss can't wait to get back to this
like do you really think we're just
gonna fall apart and completely unravel
if you don't post a makeup free selfie
no filter like we're good we're fine
we'll do okay
yeah i can i can go one day without that
i would assume you'd use that date i
don't know do some work
also if we do need to see a photo of you
we can google you whenever we want
right like we don't we don't live for
people like
these celebrities are such narcissists
they think we're just like on their feed
like
give me a photo i need another photo i
need to see you with
dog ears with that said please follow me
um please follow us it's very important
we post a photo every day funny to me
that celebrities don't understand
that when they post about politics it
makes people vote for the opposite party
like you know like it's yeah i hated
that movie watch this no i
that's your thing you guys get off
facebook it's promoting hate you mean
the way we found out about your last
movie
awesome thing that promotes your movies
that we
paid to see and now you're lecturing me
about how to vote
that is i mean that's true that's not
wrong but also
my facebook isn't hateful because
fun fact i get to control who i add to
it yeah i'm incredibly
controlling people that are posting hate
over who's in charge also it's very
elitist to not like facebook
because let me tell you a fun fact in
in suction breaks it down in teeny tiny
southern towns that's how hairdressers
book clients
that's how i got every every comedy show
was booked on us through facebook
every makeup job i got was on facebook
people use facebook as a career because
they don't get to go on tv every day
and tell their opinion so they have to
do it on facebook to their little
friends
hollywood betting's coming for you yeah
facebook is where working-class people
get work they're allowed to have an
opinion we
are protecting the working class by
trying to cancel facebook which is where
the working class gets their jobs
all you're doing is shutting down the
voices of those people because that's
where they get to voice them
that's what they get to do and also what
if what if what if tina is having a sale
on you know on on you know bleach on
some little bleach dies she's doing
in the middle of you know a clipper cut
salon and you've done shut down facebook
and now her kids can't eat when
benjamin's mad he gets more so they
ain't gonna take a trip to six flats now
because the whole watch them me yelling
jicketts
yeah they will come for you you better
watch them truly if that is such an
elitist thing to be like we hate
facebook and then be in a tv show for it
or whatever the hell that is that's
ignorant you guys bettin's pissed off
i just don't get it it's like you other
people can have opinions too and if i
don't like the opinion
i can bl i really have more control on
facebook and instagram than i do
anywhere else in my life
in real life if you're being afforded a
restaurant i can't make you leave being
full i have to leave okay on facebook i
can get rid of you in a heartbeat i'll
never just see you again
you'll never see me again i'm afraid to
cut you off benden because you are done
now
yeah okay you're done you're good just
wanted you to know
[Laughter]
whoo guys benton let it be known
loud and clear hillary duff i love you
guys thank you
turn my elephants don't write elephants
you guys we are so effective
at talking about our sponsors that our
producer is
currently activating his daily harvest
subscription
wait let's look at chris's order chris
is actually because of the way we have
so elegantly eloquently
passionately and accurately spoken about
the delights of daily harvest
he has taken matters into his own hands
and ordered the
the strawberry and peach smoothie oh
that's my favorite we're getting in
touch with this feminine side right over
here
okay heard heard heard her heard it
think of me
lady harvest is really it's very
convenient like literally whenever
you're like can you be here in five
minutes like let me grab my harvest and
i jet out the door
i know well also it's just like fruit is
such a nightmare
okay well because here's like this is
this is why i love daily heartburn the
easiest food to eat
it's because fruit isn't sabotages your
entire existence because you get oranges
and then you get bananas and they all go
bad at different times and it's like
you never know when the banana's bad but
you want banana and orange but the
orange isn't ripe yet and then you want
pear but the pear is
rotten now oh do you know what i'm
saying you eat fruit different than me i
buy fruit and i mean it all right then
all at once i get six oranges that's
what i wanted how many
six you're being funny today benton
that's not a joke that's really how i
eat so i like daily harvest because it's
all these different fruits already cut
up
already in the fridge like fruits that i
would never be so brave as to attempt
yeah to put a nice dragon fruit where do
you even start i don't even know what
they taste like
everyone says you need to eat dragon
fruit it's so healthy don't even know
how to approach a dragon fruit in the
store
terrified it feels sacred i don't want
to touch it thank you thank you daily
harvest
for making dragon fruit accessible yeah
and cacao don't know where to buy that
but i really enjoy it don't
frankly don't know what it is chocolate
sugar it's some sort of chocolate and i
like it uh
the cold brew i love it's like you know
i have to put coffee yeah the cold brew
i have to have coffee at all times and i
don't know how they do this but they
have um
they have one that's chocolate and
hazelnut it's a smoothie that's already
all pre-cut in
and uh it has avocados and they're fresh
right there
oh yeah this wasn't really stupid
beautiful but i love the fact that
because they're frozen out to add any
ice
that can i tell you ice is a hassle i
sometimes i don't even know if i have
eyes it's a
nightmare you gotta break it up and then
it falls everywhere and then you can't
pick it up off the ground it keeps
slipping out of your hands it's like
trying to pick up soap in prison
yeah you don't know what's gonna sneak
up behind you when you're picking up
that ice it's dangerous
i don't have an ice maker and neither do
you because you're relatable so we have
to scoop it out with our hands and that
is
it's not i don't like the ice pick
around the house i can't let benton
loose with this temper and an ice pick
in my own home
who knows what would this temper you
know me daily harvest
you know what to do daily harvest makes
it easy to eat clean undeniably
delicious food no matter what you're
doing you know what i like to call daily
harvest it's a no-brainer
you can see what you like to call it you
can't mess it up it's just like you know
what i like daily harvests because i
feel like i have
i i have everything i need in that one
septa brain smoothie
but then like the rest of the day i can
kind of be sloppy with my food because i
started with daily harvest and i got all
my vitamins and stuff
that's science i think that's how health
works for you
keep it simple that's what it is simple
with daily harvest go to
dailyharvest.com
enter promo code good for you and get 25
off your first box did you get 25 off
chris yes
that's promo code good for you for 25
off your first box at dailyharvest.com
you deserve it get your immune system on
point
dailyharvest.com cut the shit
um benton you know i'm out there on
dates
i know um i'm out in the wild i'm in the
jungle
good place to find dates um are you
wearing meat undies on these dates
well that was an organic segue well
we're in this we're in the ad section
they know
we tell them beforehand i'm telling you
i thought me undies
you know that i've been wearing the
undies i always wear them to work out
because they don't move and give you a
front thong
they don't try to chainsaw you in half
the the
sides of the underwear just stay all day
without giving you a rash without
cutting into you
they really do and they don't move
around listen i have
large balls no what
please don't mention my genitals i have
a lot what are you republican
i have large balls oh my god legs
what is wrong with you what we have to
start over no we don't no start
over i will leave yeah put it on a
little bit do not post that
bye i'm contacting a lawyer who are you
calling
a lawyer we're starting over you tricked
me that was gas fighting
no it wasn't that wasn't that was your
subconscious
no it wasn't cause that's not true i
would never say that first of all
oh my god i hate the show i'm never
coming back i fucking hate doing this
you're a monster
this is so stupid snapped you snapped
you just went into a total spiral based
on something you said
i did not want to say it you said it and
then i repeated you on accident i've
just been sitting
here i've done nothing i'm saying that
you are the next one let me tell you
who the next challenge oh and it's alex
am i toxic okay
please buy me undies but okay let's go
to court okay we're going to court
will you please say your statement of
why you're suing me
i haven't came out again i'll think of
some things okay good i can't i can't
wait to hear your
your your ball retort first i wouldn't
see you so shut up
okay anyways oh i think you're frazzled
because you're thinking about me wearing
me undies
you're thinking about how sexy what i
was gonna say was that i have big thighs
and then i wear briefs and they never
cut into me either which is very
shocking for men's briefs
yeah well i have a very big labia
were you trying to fit in now we just
started that over
no we don't this is it i'm not starting
it over this is it this is the only me
undies ad we will ever do again just
please repeat this one
until we lose them as a sponsor look me
undies
you know this i've posted
myself in me undies they're like velour
um it's like cake it's like wearing
a piece of cake as underwear it's like
a car a little caramel just grazing your
genitals
what are you talking about i'm just
trying it's the world they're the
world's most comfortable underwear
they're the softest nicest underwear and
they guarantee they'll give your money
back
also they have halloween prints coming
out soon ooh glow ghosts
yeah so that when uh i show my i wonder
if they have them on a bra for your
boobs
when i take uh my uh clothes off and i
have my little ghost undies for the guy
i'm dating i'm like don't ghost me
well just so you know this is haunted
when he goes down i just go boom you're
like welcome to my haunted house sir
guys love that me undies has a great
offender for whitney's listeners for any
first-time purchasers you get 15
off of free shipping this is a
no-brainer especially because they have
a hundred percent satisfaction guarantee
which i mentioned
earlier you'll be extra satisfied oh my
god
if that becomes a thing i'm literally
gonna lose my mind to get your 15
off your first pair free shipping and
100 satisfaction guaranteed
go to meundies.com whitney that's
meandes.com
whitney been a pleasure having you guys
as a sponsor farewell
i'm gonna sneeze you guys okay i'm gonna
try to hide it
oh my god or cry are you okay oh my god
do you want me to get you i really don't
need a tissue i'm just it's a fire
it is i know i've been congested
everyone's thinking i'm like on cocaine
because i was like
everyone's like um you make or you have
coven which is terrible did you see the
meme that went around that was like i
used to cough to cover my fart but now i
fart to cover my cough
oh my god so good such a mom
sorry you laughed and i love it
that's more than a laugh i don't know if
that's like truly funny to me that is
like
my kind of humor one-on-one um okay
have you ever done a podcast like this
no i love it how did we get
you how did why are you doing that you
texted me why are you here
does your publicity doing that i just
told her thank you
i was like fyi this is what a bad client
i am i don't
they they find out things and they're
like did you want to mention
i'm like oh yeah yeah yeah but it's
usually like a friend or something
i can't believe i conned you into doing
this you didn't have to call me i was so
excited
i have to be honest this we've had a lot
of really fancy people on this podcast
see that's why i was like i ought to be
a part of that fancy crew truly that's
how i get guests i just try to
capitalize on their insecurities make
them feel left out that's how i'm able
to get people to do this
but um this is by far the most pressure
i felt of anyone
why because we're friends i know but
we're friends like
for real from we didn't we met in a way
that was like i know you kind of for you
but i have i work with a lot of
younger people that you're like their
god
oh my god is that i mean that's stress
it just makes me feel really old
i mean and then sometimes really cool
like
so there's this artist that my husband's
obsessed with phoebe bridgers
and i mean i'm obsessed with her too
she's amazing
and um we went to her show it was
actually the first
outing we went to after i had banks like
i think she was maybe two weeks old and
so i was just like
milky and gross and just like you know
you know how milky and gross yeah like
just i'm just like a milk machine like
yeah it had just kind of
just comes out without you don't get to
schedule it or
there's not like a button i just i truly
don't know bitch
are fake so i don't even know what would
come out just like tupperware
i don't know even though oh my god no
well you eventually get on a schedule
and then like if that's a feeding time
do i need to talk into this thing
you're the famous musician i feel like
you know way more about microphones than
i do at this point
um if if if uh like in the beginning
you're just kind of like the baby's
feeding on demand so you just
like have milk all the time okay which i
i'm talking a big game because i
actually don't even make that much milk
which is really sad for me but
um anyway we go out a lot of women
that's like we can go
into that milk shaming i know it's
lactation shaming out there
it's worse than being pregnant honestly
breastfeeding like it there's that
really sweet connecting moment
and you're like i'm feeding my child and
like you know
it's lovely it's so incredibly painful
in the beginning
then if you don't make enough milk which
i never did you've like
sat there for over an hour feeding your
baby
and then you're just like and i have to
go make a phone formula because i'm not
enough i didn't make enough it's still
hungry it's still crying it's never
gonna go to sleep like it just
it sucks you feel like is there an app
for that
there's an app like everything these
days haven't we beat this technology
isn't there better technology
than it's called formula yeah why do we
what and what does it feel like is it
little biting like they just eventually
that goes away
and it doesn't hurt but like for me for
six weeks it felt like
someone was like slicing my nipple off
with like a razor
like horrible like like like shards of
glass which is not pleasurable for you
no it's not enough it's not a nice
aggressive thing not in a good way in a
bad
very bad anyway um i was going on to
phoebe bridges because
it was our first outing and i'm like in
the car like pumping pumping pumping
like i'm gonna make it through a concert
i'm gonna make it
right and then i don't know how he knew
someone
was there but like phoebe found out we
were there and she was like i started
singing because of her and i was like
first of all she's like eons way more
talented than i am so i was like that is
amazing but like sometimes i hear cool
stories like that where i'm like
that's pretty cool but i still it still
makes me feel old no it's really
um i know when people come up to me and
they're like i watched you as a kid and
like you're my hero i'm like oh god that
means i have crow's feet like i need to
go exfoliate
um yeah so it's always like a little bit
of a bittersweet compliment but it is
wild because i have not had this kind of
reaction from people
um this comedian i'm writing with right
now taylor tomlinson she's 26 years old
and she's like you don't understand like
she is me and i am her like it's a very
intense
you're like she acts just like that yeah
yeah
but it made me think because i always
start the podcast contextualizing how we
know each other if we're real friends if
we're being hollywood phonies what it is
because that's the whole point of
podcasting is we don't have to like go
on talk shows with people we're
pretending we're friends with
and having this inauthentic conversation
that's been pre
you know scripted i when i first met you
i and i'm also obsessed with how we
project onto people
and throw our insecurities at other
people and our fear takes over
i feel like when i first met you i was
probably a bitch
because i completely ignored you because
i remember going like she's so famous
just leave her alone like this because
we like worked out together in the same
space
oh my god wait i never feel like you
were a bitch to me see see
i'm obsessed with the things we invent
in our heads that
never happened because i was i would
spend so much mental energy being like
just say hi to her and leave her alone
just let her have this time because
it just makes me think like when you're
this famous you never get you don't ever
get time off from being famous
oh my god you're so funny i feel like
the fit like
i don't ever feel like i'm that famous
but thank you so much
that's because everyone's pretending
you're not because that's way more
important
we're all pretending we don't know who
you are so you don't think you're famous
that's so funny
is that what it is yes because we're all
like don't look at her don't make her
feel weird
and we got half the time i'm like i
don't belong here i'm not cool enough to
be here
wow so everyone's like completely
ignoring you because they're trying to
not
make you uncomfortable so now you really
do feel like you're not famous
okay so much
i tell my husband that i'm like i'm so
nervous like i don't know why and
meanwhile they're like
she's like i don't want to be the
asshole who's like yes
but in reality she's like you're like
what
you know the difference there's famous
there's notorious
and then there's like beloved and i
think that you have this
beloved thing where people very much
feel like um
connected to you on like a soul level
it's not like oh they're like you're the
only person where friends were like can
i come i'm like no
you can't come like famous people
friends of mine who are
truly famous were like can i come oh my
god what i know
i thought it was weird too i was like
pull yourself together
oh my god i'm dying i feel a lot of
pressure to like get this right and
everyone is sending me questions to ask
you
and i just kind of want to let's
definitely go through all of this i just
want to like hang out with you um
so okay so what is your what is our
relationship
i don't know i was just sitting in my
head thinking well there was a time you
didn't hire me for that job
and you were tripping on um being a
bitch to me at a gym
no no everybody i'm kidding
the thing she was really a bitch about
is that i didn't get that job
i'm just kidding um i love you think i'm
the only person that got to
make that decision no no no um well
first of all that
is i don't know if i'm forgetting about
the gym part but like
when we first like the first time i met
you you were like
lovely to me in the audi like helping me
working me through the audition
and like that's how that's my first
recollection but
i'm a little brain dead and then we
worked out together and
we were in the same gym and we'd
sometimes have the same time slots and i
remember
watching her work out and you are such a
beast
and i just remember being like god like
she's so gorgeous she's so elegant she's
so sweet she's so funny and then you
would just like be doing these like box
jumps you were like
like covered in like chains like i mean
just like lifting
lifting five times your body weight and
i was like she's just like a little
beast
i am a little beast i feel like i've
always been that way
like i've always been just a grit like
you have grit
where does that come from i don't know
i really don't know i think it's just
kind of who i am my daughter's like that
and my mom
from the day i was born was like hillary
you could
apply red lipstick better than me by the
time you were like three and a half but
you could climb trees higher than all
the boys
and i was like that really does sum up a
big part of my personality like i feel
like i'm really feminine and girly and i
love like
to smell good and i love to like make
potions and i love to do like hair
makeup and fashion and blah blah but
like
i i do really love to like push myself
and i grew up being a gymnast and um
and i really love food too so do i
so you basically are like i do this so
that i can indulge myself
um so have you carried that on with your
daughter
in terms of like allowing her to climb
trees and not
you know because i feel like the moms
that let their daughters
put themselves in danger the ones that
had grit like you have yeah
um i try to keep her alive
obviously but i don't really
hover at all like she i mean the other
day i found her in the chicken coop
you know so she's she's monitored
but she's like also i have a pod going
on at my house right now with
like lucas he's eight and so four
eight-year-olds and they'll be
you know they do their pe and their
recess outside and i have a lovely
backyard with like an in-ground
trampoline and
you know just space for them to run and
sometimes she'll there'll be four
big kids on the trampoline and then she
has like
locked her legs out like just like stiff
knees where
her body doesn't bend and she's just
like like just being bounced up so high
and if i try to pull her off she's like
no
no no like she's just like she's
she's tough do they know you're famous
um some of the kids do yeah
that that happened in first grade where
oh my god one of my son's friends oh no
my son did it to me luca did it to me
your son recognized you but he had no
idea what i did for the longest time
like he saw me on the cover of a
magazine once and we were like it's just
at the grocery store and i think it was
like cosmopolitan
or something like kind of kind of hot as
sex tricks yeah
exactly oh my god no i think there was
something about anal right by my head on
that particular
that particular not how you were
conceived what i should have done
but no he's my good child yeah right
that's right that's right the one
um i'm kidding they're both good all the
time perfect angels
all the time um watching this in 20
years
i think he thought like oh yeah and then
it's just shane's mommy's turn like next
week
like on the cover of the magazine you
know like he just thought like oh
mommy's rotate on this oh my gosh moms
are on magazines yes
cut to you photoshopping your these are
the other kids moms onto cosmopolitan
but he so he got in the car this is like
maybe a year after that he got in the
car i picked him up once and he was like
i know your name and i was like i hope
so
you're in first grade you know and he's
like but i know your real name
and i was like what what's that and he
was like hillary duff
and i was like caught yeah you knew that
yeah and then it was like i'm like
i forget what happened after that my
story is a bust but he just kind of
it was funny he obviously knew my name
but someone at school must have said
like
i know who your mom is and it's this and
so like my name all of a sudden became
this like different kind of
secret like thing and i was like yeah i
kind of had to have the talk like
you know not all mommies are on the
magazines and not all mommies are on tv
and yes dog we've you've come to set and
watched her on
set oh and he can't there's nothing
worse for him it's like pulling his
fingernails off to come to set
he's like why are you doing the same
thing over and over again
he doesn't understand it's so
interesting to me that having to have
that conversation with your kid have
they seen any of your
work mm-hmm not so interested not i'm
not fans not a fan
not a fan of my work no and i actually
reached out i did the first like
thing where like i would try to pull a
string as like a celebrity mom
because people have pulled so many
strings with me over my whole entire
career like
i never do this and that's usually like
i don't know rita wilson and tom hanks
someone you know and they're like but
you know um so i called my
manager the other day and i was like yo
this steven universe get me on it i
don't know how like i need to be a voice
on steven universe
luca would freak out and she's like oh
okay i'll look into it cause me back
she's like they stopped shooting two
years ago
like oh okay that's now your car your
choices are basically how to get on
shows that your kids are gonna think i'm
cool yeah
yeah do you watch the shows with them
well i watched steven universe with luca
and it's like a thing that we do
together
and it's pretty hardcore like i'm
invested and it's not completely painful
it's actually really good there's
something funny to me about like
thinking of tom hanks
being forced to watch lizzie mcguire
with his kids yeah or like
like um steven oh my god i'm drawing a
blanket uh-oh google whatever
colbert dwarf no ammo even tyler tyler
yeah it's like he came and played santa
stephen
[Laughter]
i feel like that was the first celebrity
i met in hollywood and i was like oh my
god
stephen yeah i mean
on a good day um
wait i've lost steven tyler like him
playing santa claus on lizzie mcguire
you know he didn't want to do that like
his guys made him do that
for sure right everybody is obsessed
with this lizzie mcguire
what why is this chick this chick what
is it
i i think i know it's just because
you're just so magical and relatable
and what is it why i don't know is there
a bigger icon legend or star than lizzie
mcguire
i'm trying my mine was hannah montana i
almost said that
but i don't think that's her job main
job is to be a dick to me
to keep her humble and i like this
everything i shut her down all
right everyone needs one
is that annoying i tell her all the time
i'm the boss but can i tell you maybe
this is why you're so sane and humble
because the main
thing that people were telling me last
night when i was talking about you is
like how come she hasn't gone crazy
how come she's not a nightmare it's you
you've kept her in check
become a nightmare before me no i did a
pretty good job before her
how did you credit whitney yeah it must
know it can't be you who was it like
leave the room now
okay between your mom and you yeah my
mom did a really good job
there's there's this funny story that
that my mom i came home
literally six minutes late when i was
17 and a half years old and my mom took
my cell phone away for like a couple of
days and i was like she's savage
it finally clued and i was like i paid
that bill i want my phone back
but like you have this mortgage exactly
i pay for all the clocks that
are how you know i'm late yes yes
exactly that did not clue in for like a
long time
which is not like it's not like i was so
sheltered i was definitely like
i went out to clubs and like did my
thing and you know my mom was
great with not like she didn't spend all
my money which is so wonderful you know
the bar is low
for moms thank you for not spending all
my money
yeah drugs thanks ma i it kind of is
that a lot of the time which is so sad
and i want to talk about your
relationship okay because
how much time do we have i oh this goes
on for about
most episodes are like three hours so
you're gonna have to drag us out here
tooth and nail
you're just you're just gonna have to
drag her out
um i have a theory that i knew you were
gonna get married before you did
you did wait to him yep oh okay why
i saw you two at rusty's dog store
oh yes once yes and i saw you before
that at katsuya i want to say
like i saw you two once i didn't say hi
once we did okay and i saw the way he
followed you out like you were leaving
the sushi restaurant
and he kind of was like shielding you i
can't explain it he like had his hands
sort of behind you and was walking
behind you and i was like oh they're
gonna because i got a big ass he's like
he was hard you were gonna tip over you
had super high heels on and that
bubble ass like your body's dangerous
like you are
it's not safe for you to walk around in
the world it's like does she follow up
why is he hovering around her like that
and i remember just going that is love
like that
is i remember being like i hope she
knows him because that guys
or if she's going to marry that she's
going to marry her or he's going to kill
her one no in between
when did you know honestly i didn't even
know
when we had a baby together
this is the kind of shit i love yeah
yeah we actually love to talk about this
all the time because
we had this you know we broke up twice
once i broke up with him
after how with me the first one was like
a six-month run
with like a a year in between and then
why what were you what was your logic i
was like separated from my husband like
i wasn't even fully divorced yet
we were definitely like living apart and
able to like see other people and we
knew
it was going to be over but it was just
complicated my son was like two and a
half
i was like starting to make a record he
was really busy
um touring and stuff so i don't know it
just
it kind of fizzled and didn't feel like
we were gonna have a lot of time to
um like spend together and grow and
whatever like
it just kind of and what's the rule on
how soon
he could meet your uh luca he didn't
meet luca that time around
and he didn't even meet luca until we
started dating the second time
and i'd say for three months for a
couple months wow because i would
imagine a big part of it is seeing how
they interact
yeah huge but like he's such a sensitive
like he he you know if you tell him one
time you're like oh
i'm having this thing and i want to
well he'll be like oh i know book like
he'll like go buy you a book and just be
like he's just so
you know engaging with people and lovely
um
so i knew that he was going to be great
with luca he also i have
a ton of like parallels with his mother
um
shocker i know i love the they love
their mothers
i know we're actually want to marry him
um his mom had a son who
is 10 years older than uh matt and they
like obviously live together all the
time but like matt's dad
basically raised uh chris and so i don't
know it's just
it's like a lot of the same but chris
was never like i don't think matt even
knew chris was his half brother for the
longest time
huh you know and so i think that that
never part of my life never scared matt
do you and his mom get along really well
so well she called me on the way over
here
when we fight i call her what is this i
tell on him
all the time she's all like get to work
and she's like and i talk to rhonda and
yeah rwanda also what a name ronda will
ream his ass for like
ron i'm calling rhonda
yeah she's the best she's also a
therapist so like
i know rhonda the therapist and
mother-in-law
she's gonna love this damn right i would
not fuck with
rhonda no she's a therapist jesus she's
amazing
she's amazing that's so cool i feel like
you should tell her about um
order
she gets big this gal likes to shop and
she got a big shop up
here's the thing about shop can we just
for a second shop up i feel like in the
last six months i've gotten too old for
shop up
oh really everything's like got poofy
shoulders
i don't know if they're prom dresses
like they've got like i'm just like i
just got too old everything's like
biking shorts
you just have to stick to net a poor day
it's very i think so it's very i have to
graduate it's too like coachella for me
it's like lots of belly strings and such
but for like jeans and like basic
like jeans that's in the work she'll
spend more time on shopbop than
listening to me about working oh yeah no
i'm on shop up true
right now frankly i'm please keep
talking no all
adding to cart all day all benton does
his return except for this
except for that on shopbop your freaking
cart disappears after 15 minutes of not
purchasing
it and then you'll put two hours in
making the cart and you're like
i end up just screen grab screen grab
screen grab and i'm like can you handle
this
thank you it's gone nothing's in the car
that is the story of my life adding
things to cart so meticulously for like
45 minutes and then i go and they're all
gone waste of the day oh my god i know
okay so rhonda
uh so she's just telling i sent her a
huge bot i sent her a pair of boots
as a gift from shop and then
i next order and then my next order i
forgot to change the address have you
ever done that
and i sent her a ginormous box of things
that had like nipple pasties
and like underwear like everything was
like so small
watchless dominate trick suit yeah
yeah like petals yeah but yeah the
little ones that are like look like um
i should have gone i should have like
gone deeper with that
matt's on this thing right now he
doesn't like nipples so it's just i have
to cover them up
she wouldn't believe me probably you
guys should just start uh you should
just buy
start buying two of everything and just
start dressing exactly like you wanted
your mom
you got better here i am okay so you
broke up with him the first time
timing uh is everything didn't work out
the second time
yeah he wished me happy birthday on my
birthday
and isn't that right we were like i
might have been seeing someone i don't
know
i know well that person might kind of
been back and forth with too so i don't
it wasn't so serious anyway
he i was coming back to new york i was
coming back to l.a i was shooting in
new york and i was almost like at the
tail end and he's like
something about sushi wait was this the
time i can't remember anything right now
when did he reach out on um when did he
reach out through
words with friends he poked me on words
with friends that poked you oh the poke
poke is you know so good if you're gonna
poke me sir it better be in
person it's not so funny yeah oh this
was the third time i really can't
remember
it's it's messy it got really messy this
is a roller coaster
i think you saw me at sushi when the ti
if you didn't say hi to us probably that
was like the first time we were like
getting back together we
always go for a sushi meal and then it's
like we're back or the race is done
yeah so then we started dating again
that was like six months and then
he broke up with me because the third
why
the third he didn't poke him back i i
didn't
actually i think i poked a little too
hard what was his one
in the wrong hole sorry sir what what
was his reasoning
we had a kind of mess a really i had a
rough night
[Music]
i gave i really gave him a piece of my
mind one night it was kind of emotional
time for me and
um and he was just like yeah we're not
this is
not good right now you just let it out i
did which i'm always torn on because
it's like i think we have to be
authentic in our relationships but at
the same time my therapist is always
telling me about restraint of pen and
tongue not everybody needs to know
everything
and your person isn't your dumping
ground and i was like no but i'm being
authentic
i just like let out all my feelings and
emotions and she's like no no that's not
for him
that's for your therapist that's for
your girlfriends like you have to
restrain
you know what i will say i will say that
there was some things going on that we
needed to work out
and he kept putting them off putting
them off putting them up and so i was
like there's just this like
this like thickness in the air that i
can't
change yeah and and i don't work that
way like i've
one thing that's so great about our
relationship we will have an explosive
fight like every
two couple days maybe couple weeks
totally normal right yeah totally um
i would i would say probably every two
months we have like some we gotta like
cleansing a purging yes and it always
ends like constructively and lovingly
and great
but like we never are at each other's
throats or like
nippy with one another or never passive
aggressive no
i can't i can't that's horrible that
sounds really smart it's like a purge
it's like a marie condo like it just
took us a while to get there
and the whole thing of me being like i
feel like we need to talk about
this thing and i i'm feeling this and i
you know even if you're not like it's
still real for me blah blah blah
and he was just kind of like and so i
just like let him have it one night
and he was like see ya was that new york
yeah
and do you know anything about like your
love language or any of that
i don't know a ton about that it's
interesting because i find a lot of
times
a lack of communication for me i
translate to rejection
and abandonment and being dismissive
like i fill in the blanks
yeah so you have the conversation and
then you've made it all up in your head
all of it
all i've projected everything if i don't
hear from you i will make up your
dialogue i will just write your
script i'll write the script i sent you
this i'll send you the salmon pages and
i just need you
that's so good that's so dumb the
goldenrod pages
and so for me i need a lot of
communication it's taken me a really
long time to not fill in the blanks
negatively and just go let me just wait
to hear what the person actually has to
say instead of making up their inner
monologue
yeah totally and approaching it like
i've learned i have to ask a lot more
questions instead of like tell
like well why why did you i'm trying to
think i'm trying to go back
well you just probably did that because
you thought i was gonna be mad at you
right
yeah and then they're like well you're
why are you talking me into my
thoughts yes yes wow that's such a good
piece of advice just ask them ask more
questions yeah don't tell them
yeah i'll i'll i'll basically give you a
lead
especially if i don't want to leave
especially if i don't want a red flag to
come up especially if i'm conveniently
trying to avoid the truth
to not have the relationship end i'll be
like well you just did that because
you're insecure because your childhood
right
that's why you did that whitney
no you just texted that girl because
like she texted you and you didn't want
to be rude and like you just want to be
nice
right is that why that's not dying
that's right that's why
that's the reason why yeah okay good
we're good okay moving on like i
don't want to ask because then i'm
risking because you don't want to know
i'm risking the truth yeah and i'm gonna
get hurt yeah
yeah so then how did you so what was
nice about ours was that
it leveled the playing field and i was
like if you can't even let me like come
and properly apologize
which he did not let me do um
that's not for me like we're not ever
gonna be able to communicate well you
know
so we just really literally stopped
talking remember how long he left his
damn guitar at my house i was like
finally i put a deadline on it and i was
like okay well i'm leaving your
guitar at the guard gate and it'll be
there for 24 hours putting it on ebay i
signed it and i'm putting it on ebay
yeah
some guys the guys can be such jerks
well he left the guitar
i think he knew what he was doing i
don't like that shit laying around
like no he clearly that was his way of
saying like i'll be back
well he wasn't i was like your guitar is
going to be at the guard gate for 24
hours like
and then what happened and he went and
got his guitar and then i had to move to
new york so we were like it was anyway
it was kind of just like
and i was so sad i was really sad
i got a puppy i got momo healthy
very healthy i support that i feel like
sometimes matt still still holds it
against momo that he was like his
relationship
you're the rebound rescue yeah but it
was
it was a probably about five months and
then we reconnected again and that's
when he reached out
he reached out to me on campus with
friends and i used to love to play words
with friends like on set or whatever
um and so he would see i would see him
playing and
i'm sure he would see me playing but
he's always like that you on there oh
don't accidentally like
so cause like words with friends is
smart like everything else should you
watch the social dilemma that's a whole
nother i know everyone knows it yep
so it'll be like oh you played with this
person would you like to play a game
with them they're on now and you're like
no no no don't like have a flip of the
thing i cannot
like whatever so i'm always like
paranoid it's gonna accidentally like
ask him to play a game or something so
my most worst is you know that if you're
spotify friends with someone they can
see what music you're listening to
and my ex can see that i'm like only
listening to adele
and like and like break up music
how can they see that because if you're
if you add friends on spotify you can
see where your other friends are
currently listening to
like he can see that i'm listening to
shade like he knows he knows i'm hanging
out with someone
yeah you gotta un-add him i know
i mean it's like just kind of a go-to
that or like rage against the machine
depends on
my mood so the rage against the machine
is for the pasty
that's for the the yeah the tassel the
tassel knight no i can't feel my nipples
they've been sawed through too many
times
dead on the floor yes i had a couple
sketchy surgeons in the beginning took
me a while to land on the legitimate one
with an actual license
um yes so
he poked you on words so he he was like
do you want to play
yay oh i can't say you know a dress you
yeah on um words with friends and i'm
like i just ignored it i was driving i
think i almost wrecked my car but i'm
like i put my phone down i was like
oh just do that that feeling in your
stomach yes
yes and so then it wasn't until like a
day later
and i'm like i just texted him and i was
like
that was a slip of the thumb huh like
that was like a total mistake
and he's like what do i have to do poke
you because you can like poke someone to
be like play with me like if
they if there's no response and then i
was like
it's on so excited i just like got on i
threw some words up on the thing and
then
and then that was it and then we were
like you know we just when did floor
happen
floor happened that time what was that
what's floor so there's this band
that he's good friends with that i love
i love i love their music
and so we they were playing
in la and i was like i can't go to their
la show matt's gonna be there and
this is before this is for the poke and
so
then and lauren got obsessed with floor
and then our friend tate got obsessed
with the floor and we're like let's go
make a girls trip and go to san diego
and like rent a really cool hotel room
and like just go
seafloor and like have fun and come back
home the next day and i had just been in
new york filming forever and i was like
you know i could really have used a
break anyway so we went to san diego to
see a show just so i wouldn't run into
him
and then we started talking did you see
him well no but he knew that i went
then i had to tell him on social media
no no because
in between that time that we were
leaving and their la show and their san
diego show is when the whole
conversation happened with the
i know i know you love him i love him
so much still yeah
how did you know like how crazy too i
like sometimes i'm like
how the other day i found a spilled
smoothie on the bottom of his car
i'm sure it's been there for at least
three and a half months i was like
you're disgusting
the thing has like a green crusty
yeah i know i don't know if you just
didn't smell it he didn't i don't know
it was like i don't know so what
probably he smells too
you know that i but he's a little smelly
but here's the thing whenever
anyone complains about relationships
like the he leaves the toilet seat up
the cap off the toothpaste
if you like him it's cute there's
something endearing about it all the
things that annoy you about certain
people with the person that you're in
love with
it's like i can't stay mad at you i
don't know that you think it's all cute
but i just think that
i love him so much but he's so funny
he's so funny and he's so clever
like i really i do i love his brain so
you know what else i like about him just
the times that i've seen him
he seems very self-contained and
i would say i mean by that very
self-contained like um
like you know when you meet someone and
they feel the need to like perform for
you
or prove something to you or like he
wasn't like peacocking
or posturing like you know you i've just
seen so many people in relationships
especially with like a public figure
where they have to say i'm the boyfriend
and i'm the
you know it was just like yeah no just
what it's it's a it's almost an
imperceptible thing that's just more
body language than anything else but i
was like this guy has nothing to prove
he's not trying to be the center of
attention he's not like angling for
anything it's like
you know i think when you've been in the
public eye long enough you can feel when
someone has needy energy
yeah or they're trying to prove that
they can like keep up or something
like that i mean because because i
remember because he was just like hi and
just like kept moving and i was like oh
you didn't want nothing from me that's
insulting frankly okay
not a star fucker then you're like i'm
like hey don't you wanna okay fine
friend me i play words with friends too
hit me
i finally broke down actually on our
honeymoon we were playing um
bananagrams have you ever played that i
have not
kind of like scrambled but you guys have
already
by the way we were like playing pasties
and bananagrams this
is kinky wow that pretty much thumbs up
by the way nude pasties let's not get
crazy they're not sparkly they're not
like black
they look like an accident happened yeah
it's like an ace bandage
oh my god i cried on her honeymoon after
he beat me so bad so many times i was
like it's not fair you do words all day
long
all you do is do words because he like
writes you know
like this isn't fair and for every time
that like
i have to pick like i only want to pick
up every three times that you say peel
it's like okay that's fine so this is
your biggest fight
oh no no no no there's been a lot i mean
we fight
give the guy a break because in your
dream last night he cheated on you i
know with tiffany
how can i dare him with tiffany yeah
amber thiessen that's what he said he
said
lee thiessen and i was like at least get
it right tiffany the singer
he said tiffany lee thiessen and i was
like it's amber these
thank you i know for someone who claims
to be in love with her in high school
get it right that is an irreconcilable
difference
no tiffany's not even real tiffany the
other thing the one from the 90s
no that's just what i was trying to make
her a real person tiffany's a jeweler
that's how much he loves you he's like
yeah that tiffany engagement ring box
oh my god so he cheated uh in your dream
and what how will he pay for that
he apologized no he didn't he's just
like
he apologized for cheating on you in
your mind yes
i made a really big deal of it i was
like are you cheating on me like we need
to talk i feel like i'm like building
this whole story in my head and now
you're cheating on me and tiffany's real
and tiffany's at the studio all the time
and
do i need to come drive by and do and he
was like do i need to come remind
tiffany that i'm hillary duff do i need
to drive by
and remind her of my body and face i
really like to just make big deals of
things because i think it's funny to see
his reaction because he will be like
very genuinely like sorry and usually
i'm like fucking with him
i know we're so cruel are you monsters
no i gotta get my rocks off somehow
we're in like quarantine
okay i'm i don't like it when podcast
hosts just sloppily
and bullshit about pretending to use
their sponsors
i'm gonna go to my doordash app i didn't
know you had started the ad yet and i
was like what are you saying to me yeah
i'm authentic keep up
jump on i'm gonna show you my doordash
orders
so you see that this is really my
favorite app on the planet i doordash
joey restaurant what did i get i spent
two hundred and sixty-eight dollars
uh whoa i've gotta stop
uh smoking weed and ordering from
doordash i like this place a little too
much oh i had a bunch of friends over
for my birthday
we'll say that it was a baby we'll go
with that i had well that's the best is
when you would you say you ordered
uh a miso ramen farmer's milk that's so
weird because in your video you posted
for your birthday you had taco bell
oh interesting which also you can get on
doordash
great segue benton i'm going to turn
your judgment into a perfect address
when people know you ordered that by
yourself
zanuku chicken oh so good it's so
good so good and doordash brings it
literally you know what
when doordash delivers that it's hot
fresh and it's ready to go
and that isn't always is it hot fresh
and ready to go
that's not a joke i love ordering that
from doordash
i like doordash not even reading the ad
because you guys know this there's a big
computer screen with like a written ad
we don't have to look
from now on you tell us when you are
reading that we're authentic
so what i like is i'm a creature of
habit i'll eat the same thing every day
won't i tea i tru i will eat the same
thing every day
but i like going to doordash because it
shows me all these other things so i am
like forced to
have variety because i'm like oh i never
would have thought of that i never would
have thought of
the six this place it's like a fish
place and i was like oh yeah i'll do
that delicious delicious right the six
is the place that you were just doing
that for other people
doordash is food with all this food
saying i like that every time i go on it
shows me a different
um variety of restaurants so i'm always
getting something different sometimes i
want thai sometimes i want chinese
over 300 000 partners in the u.s puerto
rico canada and australia you know i'm
in order from there urban plates
but you also can just like look get like
soda from smart and final if you're like
out of oh yeah
i order from 7-eleven all the time it's
not just meals i think people forget
that um doordash you can also just be
like oh god i need some scotch tape
to put over benton's mouth help tape
would work
it wouldn't stick to my beard um
doordash deliveries are now contactless
as well so they keep you safe
safe super safe right now our listeners
can get five dollars off their first
order of 15
or more and zero delivery fees for the
first month when you download the
doordash app and enter code whitney
that's five dollars off your first order
and zero delivery fees for a month when
you download the doordash app
in the app store and enter code whitney
don't forget that's code whitney for
five dollars off your first order with
doordash
um it's time to do an ad for quip you
guys i hope we get through it without
benton
ordering my producers to cut parts of it
out listen
let's see if we're gonna be able to even
oh my god i hope someone's gonna mark
all the time she bullies me down someone
write them down in the comments
i'll use it my case um
this is an airtight case you got going
stop it i'm sure i have something
i would never do that that's so
disgusting you know what it actually is
is me walking around naked that's your
biggest case
no i wouldn't i would never that's
disgusting to me like that i'm named
naked no that's great i know with
someone
you're not allowed to walk around that's
a joke i'm not going to sue any i love
her
but but i am traumatized that she may
mention that in the last chapter i am
on one today i would like to talk about
my gorgeous teeth
okay aren't they beautiful my gorgeous
teeth me too let me talk about mine as
well
um i have everybody compliments me on my
teeth and i don't i don't know if
they're mocking me but
they're beautiful everyone i've never
gotten teeth whitening
anything else should i just say yeah
look i'm i'm
i my self-esteem is in the toilet one
thing i do feel good about
are my gorgeous chicklety-ass teeth and
she's segwaying into this because this
quip toothpaste truly well white it's
no joke this is i'm so obsessed with
this toothpaste but quip here's the
thing
that i love about it you know how
distracted i get like if i'm doing one
thing i'll just start doing another
thing if i'm cooking i'll just like walk
away in the house
quip tells you when to br how to brush
your teeth and for how long on each
tooth
it's got this can you guys hear it i'm
trying to push it up again it's very
cool
no you they probably can't hear cause
it's a very quiet vibration i know it's
really but i want to wake up first in
the morning here
like oh god that works but it it
basically like will stop
when you can move to the next two yeah
pulses you know because i will basically
give up at the back teeth i'm just like
ah whatever the front teeth yeah don't
fall out no one will know yeah no i
don't care
i'll just get caps at some point and
look how sexy this tutorial oh yeah it's
so sleek this part sticks
to touch my quip this part if she would
take it out the package ever
will stick to a mirror or in the
bathroom or something in the shower
who what kind of weirdo brushes their
teeth i have one in my shower and
outside the shower wow
supportive of those of you uh i watched
everything else in the shower why can't
i brush my teeth will you put this here
so that we can show them how it stays
stick it to your no i will not do that
but
it is really cool futuristic it is like
a blade runner toothpaste it really is
very chic and
mine's all black two minute timer 30
second pauses for a guided clean
it's lightweight it's sleek no wires no
bulky charger oh my god that's easy to
travel with
other electric toothbrush you have a
charger and then a cup and then a thing
and it's just like it goes to my phone
like an app on my phone i have to turn
it on
it's like a bomb that's about to go off
at any minute eco-friendly
solar battery charger to power your quip
with sunshine
isn't that poetic it's really cute too
there's a refresh bra
brag brain that's that's uh
uh uh freudian slips i was just bragging
about my teeth
refresh bag to bring your good oral care
habits everywhere you go oh it's nothing
moving tooth brushes in traveling is so
gross
oh yeah you know what i'm traveling and
the cases get all just
they get all crusty and they and you're
like should i still use that like is
that clam chowder it's growing an
ecosystem oh my god it's so gross
like is that e coli sorry i'm getting a
text from a
hot man who's turned on by my gorgeous
teeth they also have mint
or watermelon for adults watermelon
anti-cavity ingredients strong healthy
teeth join over 5 million mouths who use
quip
and save hundreds compared to other blue
tooth brushes when you get equipped
smart brush
for only 45 that's ridiculously
reasonable yeah of course start getting
rewards for brushing your teeth today
and go to get quipped dot com slash
whitney
right now to get your first refill free
that's your first refill free at get
quip dot com slash whitney
that's get g-e-t quip q-u-i-p
dot com slash whitney quit better oral
health made simple and rewarding
have you been cheated on though i'm
pretty sure yeah yeah i'm like that too
i'm always like i haven't been cheating
on them because i have what am i
thinking but you know what
not so badly that i feel like
it affects me all the time
but then obviously there's a little bit
of something in there that affects me
you know do you know what i mean like i
think when it happened and i'm not even
100 sure it happened i feel like your
gut knows we know
no but i think it was like that's fine
i'm
it's done anyway sometimes it's like
thank you for putting that nail in the
coffin yeah that i didn't
yes but it's still like by the way if
matt cheated on me i would be like
dead on the floor so that's how i know i
really love it
i mean i do think that's part of really
loving someone everyone's like oh the
jealousy a little bit of jealousy is
part of
yeah loving someone you know yeah like i
i mean it's hot that
you're mad at him that he's fake
cheating on you and your wild brain
you know there's literally like had the
conversation with him this morning
and he um i had to send a picture of my
daughter to
the pediatrician and um i can't believe
i'm telling this i don't know if i
really want to tell this
so your sister will call me later with a
lawsuit would you
serve me papers let me know we'll cut it
out my my phone was upstairs and so
he had his phone i'm like can i just
take a picture um to send to the
pediatrician but instead i sent it to my
phone to send to the pediatrician
because i was already talking to him a
bunch of other things
and right after that picture i saw a
picture of him just like brushing his
teeth
a video of him just like brushing his
teeth but he had like no shirt on and it
wasn't like by the way he's not that
person to be no shirt on but like
completely just out of the shower
like this like that looks like something
weird he would like send to me when we
were like dating
and clearly i just got cheated on in my
dream so i was like what like who's he
sending this to what is this for
it was for um like a takeover that he
had to do like this morning i was like
who just in the video two of you
brushing your teeth and he's like
i'm like who is it tiffany and she's
like oh my god you're insane
also like if i was cheating on you
that's not the video i don't know
probably it is he's such a weirdo i'd
like to think of a little better
game a little better game than that well
he doesn't really i mean i mean i'm
attracted to his game but clearly like
his game is like sending words with
friends
that's a really good point maybe that is
like a salacious sex tape in his mind
but who was the person he sent it to was
like a funny name lady something
lady yeah lady g or something like that
lady gaga
i don't know was in charge of he had to
do like a takeover
take over and he was like it's i'm
pretty sure it's a gay man i was like
okay
why does he call you half orange
oh because when we were dating uh one
time i was doing an interview for a
magazine
and it was when i was single but i what
people just didn't know we were dating
yet
and this girl sat me down during the
interview and she was really nice but
she
was so concerned that i was still single
and i was like
i couldn't just be like no no i'm not
i'm actually really happy they think you
have like a terminal illness if you're
single
and if you say you're happy you're lying
you're deluding yourself yes
and she passed me this book that she
wrote called finding your half orange
isn't that funny
and so like we really i am going to read
it i am going to buy it
i have a copy of your video thank you
please please give it to me immediately
i have to go read it right now
um anyway i don't know why i just i sent
him a funny picture like i sent him a
picture of the book after the interview
was over
and now we've just been each other's
half orange since what is that
why is it like women you can't you're
hillary duff you have
an incredible life you have incredible
you have an incredible child an
incredible family around you there's no
way you could be happy without a man
there's no way you can be complete
it's impossible i have to tell you that
i was always really happy without a man
like i i'm really happy with a man but
like
even through i'm so happy with you we've
been to hawaii so many times together
the people belmont dynamic is my
favorite people congratulated her when i
came pregnant one year because matt was
on tour
seriously isn't that funny people that
work there that knew us but can i tell
you i think that the people with the
best relationships with their partner
have great girl friendships yeah do you
know what i mean like
this is part of it you know like we're
designed to be in a village we're
designed to be around our girlfriends
all the time so that you don't take all
this
madness to him i know you know and we
take a very small portion of the madness
to him because i i
i think for me in my 20s certainly i
would just throw myself into a
relationship
abandon all my friendships that's such a
20s thing to do i know
gosh so dumb and it's so heartbreaking
afterwards i know and then you're like
crawling back with your tail between
your legs and you're like remember me
guys can i come back into your friend
groups i mean it's our conditioning too
you know we really are conditioned to
believe that our man should always come
first but to me
like but sometimes the man demands that
in an unhealthy way too
like i have to have all of you yeah no
one like really isolates and stuff
been through that one too that's hot oh
so how are you able to
have chill this gaggle of children and
do everything that you do
how do you do it but you you're the
reason now that i've met you i know how
she's able to do everything she does
no i am not i'm not i just don't
understand how you're able to do all of
this do you get tired do you get
exhausted do you get yeah i drink wine
what kind uh i drink a lot oh my god
now it's in my head i watched did you
watch the amy schumer
um cooking show with her husband um uh
amy learns to cook
yeah yeah she's on the phone with
jennifer lawrence and then jennifer
lawrence calls her a slut for drinking
sauvignon blanc
now i can't get it out of my head i feel
like such a slut muffin that's all i
like to drink
and jennifer lawrence thinks that
because it is kind of a
like uh it gets the
job done i mean give me a chardonnay i'm
gonna barf in the glass it's so gross
i mean it's not like zima i mean it's
not like a wine
cooler nice savvy on blocks out there
i love but i love a red wine too me too
me too i'm gonna go tonight
now you're gonna go sleepy time yes and
i got two kids that i gotta not go
sleepy time for
i wanna talk about your wedding because
this is a creepy thing to say but i did
have your wedding dress saved
in my instagram favorites when i was
engaged
looking for wedding dresses the jenny
pacquiao
right how did you pick that and where is
it and can i have it oh my god you can
totally i'm so
serious i'm so sad i'm never going to
wear it again so you can why not
why don't we dye
it's like this incredible it's got like
shoulder pads and like a cape on the
back right and these like long sleeves
i'm like that's exactly what i want like
cruella de vil
hot matrix modern space bitch
it's in the attic if you want to come
over yeah i'm not kidding let's dye it
um
green and pink i'm serious that dress
like forest green would be amazing oh my
god
yeah i'm probably never gonna fit in it
again but and how
was um uh the wedding i'm gonna tell you
the wedding was like the best night of
our whole entire life you look so happy
it was so much fun we're just sad that
it was over with so fast like
how did you did you do bridesmaids in
that whole thing
just because you didn't want to have to
thanks with my bridemaids my bridesmaids
yeah and she held it together too i
can't believe she did and luca wrote
wrote the like sweetest poem for our
wedding he got up and spoke and i think
i remember it was like
or at least i remember the beginning our
family is a galaxy
shooting across the cosmos um
magical dreams of mine come true
in my family's home and heart like
something so
beyond sweet i'm telling you he's a good
child i can't give that one away to you
so with this thing with the pandemic and
homeschooling is it sort of less weird
for you because you were schooled on
sets and
your schooling was so weird no it's
horrible
it's the worst thing that's ever
happened to me the worst thing that's
ever happened to me
minus the fact that i'm obsessed with
him i wanted to like and i love spending
time with him
i wanted to kill him you know what is so
hard
is i'm hard on him but not like i have
other friends that are way put more
way more pressure on their kids than him
he's really sensitive so i can't push
too hard but like i'm a very firm
believer like my mom pushed me
i'm a very firm believer that like you
gotta practice to get good at what you
you know
and how do you know a kid is sensitive
like how do you go like oh this is a
sensitive kid like how do you know when
to push and when to
i mean he just will like completely shut
down interesting or he's just not like
he can't handle it he's like he'll get
really i'm like i
rarely have to raise my voice at him but
when i do
oh my god it's like it's like i beat him
before or something like he's like oh my
god
i know i know he's a little older now so
it's not as bad but like
he's i just have to handle him with like
this also might be this just next
generation of parents
actually has the tools to be able to
raise boys without this toxic
masculinity shit like we're not doing
the
man up throwing baseballs at all of our
boys when they're five not letting
i wonder if just boys and generals are
more sensitive than we've ever known
i think they are haven't you ever like
i mean i know i've dated a couple of
guys that like
never talked never had you know never
opened up and then they do and you're
like i thought it was weak or bitch
yeah yeah early or whatever it is yeah
and then when they do they cry for like
four days and you're like okay easy
buddy i need to be able to stay
attracted to you okay let's not
i'm just losing i cannot ever have sex
with you again vagina drying up
yeah stop it i love you and you might
you might
you might just do that oh my god so that
because
i'm just fascinated by this new
generation of parents
that are allowing boys to express all
sides
and not be like put in a box of like
here are your gi joes and here's your
yeah i will say he was always really
attracted to boy things
um he did like a shopkin though for a
minute
he still loves the shopkins he's super
protective over those and i'm like share
those with your sister and he's like
some of
them are rare i'm like you don't really
care that like they've been in a box
like
forever and now she wants to play with
them and now you care like no
do are all the toys that we played with
growing up are they cancelled they're
kind of our barbies cancelled they're
all sexist mr potato head it's cancelled
is mr potato head cancer i don't know
i'm just saying is everything's in um
toy story
okay i don't know who knows i don't know
it's like it could be body shaming to
take the nose off i like honestly at
this point i'm sure every toy we played
with is problematic now oh my god well
a few of them are a few of them i think
they've like
tried to like make them yeah barbie used
to be like an anorexic mess
yeah yeah that was no good perky with
those giant boobs with no nipples like
you with your
petals covers actually
oh my god inspiration are there any like
uh because oh in quarantine
i was watching movies that i watched
when i was a kid and i looked back and i
was like
this is dark like i watched like the
wizard of oz i was like
this is so bleak it's like this 16 year
old who's like
emotionally taking care of all these
like random old creepy guys like i
watched
charlie and the chocolate factory which
i thought was like a magical movie when
i was a kid and i looked back and it's
just like so sad
it's so weird and dark and all the kids
die i mean it's like
is there anything they die i get like
stuck in
tubes and they get not dead i don't know
their parents
go get violet she's like the blueberry
like by the way no nobody died
none of those shocked none of those
things he i
tried to hold my breath the amount of
time he was in that too there is no way
he survived that thing
as far as i'm i was concerned as a child
he died
i mean i didn't know but yeah because
they were sort of like we're going to
see them at the end
or something but we in the kid that
shrunk into the little tv yeah
it was bleak i've never watched charlie
in the chocolate
what i'm i know i'm so much younger than
both of you
so and it's been a pleasure talking with
hilary jeff today
and that's all for our show it's time
for you to leave
and next week cameron diaz um
but um he is much more famous than me
though you i don't know
i show up i don't know if i don't think
you know how famous you are and i love
that
i'm happy for you because otherwise i
think you'd be i think we need to stop
talking about it because i think you'll
be very traumatized if you do find out
oh my god census came to the house the
other day do you remember when we were
at
um the we were at an animal rescue
event and there was a fan that had like
yes and you were like i literally body
checked this person
i body checked somebody i just it was
like this fan i think had like won a
contest or something but was like
holding a bunch of photos of you for you
to sign
and yeah you know when you do what we do
there's sometimes people just show up
and you don't know where they've come
from and you don't know what's going on
and i didn't even like know you i just
like i literally
like you guys we need to get rid of this
person you're like no she won a contest
i want to talk to her like you were just
like so open and
kind and you didn't have this like fear
or paranoia and i don't how have you
gotten this far without being scared for
your
safety yeah at all times there's been i
mean i want to murder you
there's been a few times where i i have
been
actually scared and i i would say that
it it in my
um just getting older i i set
bigger boundaries you know for not not
necessarily at an event like i
can kind of wrap my head around what
that is and have to just go into it with
like an openness
of this is gonna last for probably four
hours
and and sometimes you know what we're
like and with you
that's what i mean when you're done
you're done yeah and i've actually
gotten a lot more assertive
in my just daily life if i need to be
you know with people that
are i feel are like taking advantage at
a certain point i'm usually like
so willing to take a picture with you or
to say hi to you
have a quick conversation you know but i
i am a mom and i
i fight so hard for normalcy and
for my kids you know and um and even for
myself like i
i do i just walk around like pretty open
i'm an over sharer to the max i love it
and um i mean literally i was going to
tell you census showed up to our house
and my
my nanny called me and was like oh
census is here and they have a bunch of
questions they want to ask you i
literally would have been like um okay
here's who lives here and this is how
much i make and
and my husband thank god he like got the
phone call and was like ah
you can send it in the mail but when i
feel comfortable answering those
questions i would have been like
do you want to know where the safe is
like i don't know you're just so
desperate to talk to somebody
yeah and quarantine what are you doing
what's up how are
you girl you know what i was going to
talk to you about was the kid thing and
the in the homeschooling because i know
a lot of moms are like relating to that
right now
was as accepting as i am of like who my
child is
and his strengths and weaknesses being
his teacher
highlights all of the things that like
you think they need to be better at and
it's like normally
you have a normal um exposure to it
because your kids like go to school
during the day and they'll come back and
you'll be like okay we need to work on
this one thing but when you're doing it
all day long
you're like capitalize the first
like letter in the sentence yes and i
just told you that five times why is
this so competitive
don't do that again you know like
finally like week 11
you're like oh my god you're terrified
oh my god yeah i know it's so scary and
like
it was so intense i'm like thank god
teachers aren't their parents
aren't well yes aren't teachers of their
kids right right
because there's a separation where
they're like they don't have that
relationship
right you know i don't have to yes be
your boss you get to kind of be the cool
um respite when they come home and
you're like oh that teacher is really
hard but let's do the homework it gets
to be sort of like
you get to be good and they're evil yeah
but when you're the one driving the ship
all day long just totally like blurred
the lines of everything
it was horrible it's the worst most
traumatic thing yeah it's like you don't
want to be the good guy and the bad guy
you just want to be the good guy when
they come home
and playful and fun and loving and like
i gotta lay the law down sometimes
but it's also like um i was uh talking
to one of my nieces
and um was going through some of her
homework with her also like the stuff we
learned
is not true um oh my god please i need
examples oh no literally we're like
going through her history book and
you know and uh she's like yeah we're
you know studying you know thanksgiving
and i'm like oh yeah
the when the the pilgrims came over and
had a fun dinner with the native
americans and they all got along she's
like i don't think that's what happened
i'm like no no no no they gotta look
and like everyone had a wonderful deal
together christopher columbus discovered
america she's like that's not what my
textbook says
oh my god everything's been updated
everything's been updated and everything
we learned was like is completely
canceled they we
we didn't learn about like the genocide
and all that wait did you ever know
that i dressed up like an indian for
halloween and got crucified and i
completely understand why but like
exactly like you said didn't grow up
educated thinking that that was a bad
dinner no we didn't yep nope they were
friends and they shared a turkey leg and
they were posing together
not what happened no well i'm from
washington dc and we were the redskins
and i had redskins sweatshirts and i had
redskins hats and i would wear redskins
hats they're changing that now right
yeah no that's gone now
yeah but it's gone now no that's gone
that's my husband
in quarantine what's the butter with the
um orlando lakes yep
cancelled we had one with the headdress
and he was like
whoa we got one of those they're not
making them any no
no we gotta throw this butter away real
fast
yeah i get in trouble all the time for
things that i got in trouble for saying
basket case because
basket i was calling myself a basket
case i was like i'm such a basket case
today
and i got all these um letters that were
like that was
what uh was described um described world
war one
uh soldiers if they lost all their limbs
and they could fit in a basket they were
a basket case
and i was like i i'm trying to insult
myself
i'm not trying to hurt someone else i'm
trying like don't yell at me because i
have low self-esteem
i'm in this really weird like i'm just
trying to be quiet
right now which also you're going to get
in trouble for you know
your silences yeah yeah is taking a lie
right it's really scary to open your
mouth and i love that we're
in this um area where
we're all being enlightened you know and
we're all but it's it is
extremely sensitive and like like saying
basket case how are you supposed to know
that that's a term that's been used for
a long time and maybe it should be
eliminated but like should you be
crucified for it in that moment you know
like i just i feel like it's so scary to
talk and say anything
but i also think that like it's
interesting and ben and i argue about
this all the time it's like
you know i think that america
on one hand does not want to have
hollywood people tell them what to do
and how to vote and how to live you know
but at the same time we're supposed to
use our platform responsibly so i just
feel like as long as it's authentic and
your heart is in the right place there's
always going to be people that are going
to want to like
complain but most people are just love
you
and we amplify the negative shit you
know like
three people sent me a basket case thing
and i'm like everyone was mad at me yeah
they weren't
they weren't sensitive i'm blowing that
out of proportion yeah that's my shit
i know why is in this i'm not trying to
get information out of you from this
why is this lizzie mcguire thing so
secret
why is it like a like an fbi
mafia secret
well i think i've been pretty open about
it yeah of talking about just how there
was a change and it's but why is it like
we can't talk about it and you no one
knows anything what what is what
has anyone ever i talk about it all the
time yeah i think that
um
yeah exactly i'm just here's the i'm
just curious i don't want to talk
i don't want you to say anything that
you don't want it's more like i'm
fascinated because
people are so obsessed with you you
saying oh this season this she's gonna
go to new zealand like no one's gonna
not watch it
you know what i'm saying i'm just so
fascinated by the like psychology of
that
oh well i hope you're not wrong
i hope if i go to new zealand people
want to watch or lizzy
i don't mean like they are going to
watch this thing regardless of how many
spoilers are given away so i'm just sort
of obsessed with the
shrouded and i don't think that it's
by the way there's nothing to be like
that secretive about except for that
we had to like regroup and re like end
like pivot
yeah and i think that them being a
newish
network by the way they're like crushing
it and doing phenomenal but like this is
a big thing for them and it's actually
it's also a really big thing for me
and something that i didn't think i
would ever revisit
and then you know opening the door
and and it sounds so cheesy to say heart
but really my heart
like something i've worked my whole
entire life to try not to be lizzie
mcguire
and even though i'm
like i love her and i'm so grateful for
that like i did spend a lot of time
being like i'm different i'm something
else i'm you know and now i'm like oh
she's the best yeah you know i love her
and i love that
and and the thought of doing it again is
really exciting for me and really huge
but it just has to be done the right way
and i think we
i think what was secretive about it was
that we kind of like came
but but it had not butted heads a little
bit but like they had to do what's right
for their network and i was like well i
have a responsibility
you know so we're on a really good track
and i think everything's looking good
but i think they were just like
you know protective of what people knew
and
same with me like that's it it's not
that like story line is protected it's
more like
oh we're we're pausing yeah we're gonna
see if we can
so as someone that has been on the other
side of this is
as well um
it's so hard to do that when there's a
machine there's a
train going in one direction you have
all these people you have all these
this money at stake you have all this a
really big train
like arguably the biggest train i mean
disney arguably the train yeah going in
one direction i just remember seeing it
and just going god
i don't even know what happened here but
i know she is a fucking badass
i don't even know what happened and like
i mean i've been
you know in in situations that are not
even a fraction of as stressful as that
and it's just like i just
that is some boss shit you're so you're
so kind thank you
um there are more times within the last
few years where i sat down and i'm like
i am a boss
i am tough i am strong i am this but you
know that's not my normal like overall
feeling of myself
that was a very easy thing for me to do
like i
but lizzie mcguire would never be lizzie
mcguire without the people
that cheered her on so
naturally and authentically it was the
fans no one knew that little show on
disney channel was gonna like do what it
did
and then it just lived on and lived on
and lived on and
you know i think it just touched people
at the right time and whatever
i did that brought to the table like it
just from something worked
you know and so to have that little
hiccup and that bump the road and then
just just be like totally quiet
i couldn't i didn't do it and i opened
up myself to her and
you know um and the conversations with
disney were like keep go
it was all like very positive but
confusing yeah
and so i was like well i gotta say this
you know yeah
and it was just a responsibility to the
people that love her and the people that
got so excited
yeah and and um it's almost like you
spoke for all the fans it's almost like
you had to take on
everyone yeah i can't like just silently
not
not not do this so it's it's i pray to
god it still happens and i'm so excited
and there's some new
like players and i'm still super super
involved i have to go shoot younger
first
um and then you know hopefully we'll be
like up and running again because i
think it could be really special and i
know they feel that way i know that
they're like
measure twice cut once that's the whole
thing imagine yeah imagine doing
something that you're so proud of that
touched so many people and like getting
it wrong
i can't what's yeah can you imagine
anything more devastating
yeah i don't know if it was going to be
wrong but i just mean like
not exactly um
aligned with your heart or soul or
spirit or instinct all we have is our
instincts
that's all we have anyway especially as
an actor
all you have is your gut yeah and i just
i feel like
i was thinking about you because um my
last special i had you know uh was
talking about getting engaged and i
found i lost
so many i gained so many people then i
feel like i lost a lot of girls who
thought that i was like
their single friend and that i got
engaged and like oh we're you know just
like
having to age publicly and sort of this
pressure to sort of stay
who you've always been like i just felt
like all this pressure not even
close to as public as you are i i felt
this pressure of like oh i have to stay
broken i have to stay crazy i have to
stay in my 20s forever i have to stay
single forever because that's how people
know me
and then i found myself actively not
maturing and growing because i was
worried i would lose some people
i was worried that they wouldn't feel as
connected to me or related to me you
know so it's an interesting thing to
have to do that
publicly you know you've had no problem
with it um it seems like
oh no i think that you're wrong are you
kidding i was so scared to like
have a baby yeah grow up you know like
almost my whole entire life he'll be
like you're so great never change
yeah yeah we stay little izzy forever
like i
i can't like i'm a human being you know
so definitely maybe not in my
you know 20 mid 20s or something but
like younger than that when i'm like i
want to go
like yeah you know yeah um
but that's hard because
you know it's never great to feel stuck
right or to be a kid
even to like think that your fan base
only will accept you in this way
but really they love you yeah and they
want to grow too which is so interesting
because everyone that um
is i've have to block them on my phone
because they won't stop texting me about
you
they're like we've watched her grow and
we watch her have a baby and we watch
her get this beautiful house like
they're like
they feel like you're their best friend
and have love to like watch you flourish
you know i think in
in comedy i have this thing where it's
like you have to be crazy for people to
like you you have to be like a mess or
something and it's like taking me a long
time and like
watching you has been very inspiring to
go like no like
people that love you want you to win you
know and i think a lot of times in my
girlfriendships or you know
um that i think people can relate to
listening like if
your friends are don't celebrate when
you grow and good things happen to you
they're not your friends you know
sometimes you only have friends when
you're down and they
you know want you to fail or want you to
be a master you're happy to see you
there
you lose friends sometimes when you grow
and when you edify yourself you know you
can't take everyone with you
so how do you decide what to share and
when to like take the
steps forward or leaps and like you know
such a good question and i it's like a
natural thing where you just like
i'm tired like i can't do it anymore
what you said about um the thing with
your half orange when you snapped
there's just only so much time you can
hold something in
and when i start feeling like i'm
carrying shame or being inauthentic or
phony or fake
yeah that's when i go like oh i'm just
lying to people yeah and that feels
weird i need to release that i need to
share that
and there are other times when i'm like
you know what i don't need to shit like
when i went through my
my breaking up with my engagement
everyone was like so excited for me
because i was like the girl that was
like never gonna get married and like
you know it's like people think if
you're a woman who's single that your
life must be like so miserable
um and i felt all this pressure to not
tell
everyone um but then i started feeling
inauthentic and like i was lying and
betraying people
and i was feeling like all this shame
and i couldn't make i couldn't be funny
i also couldn't be funny because i
couldn't make jokes i had to keep
pretending i was engaged so i just like
i was like oh my job is to show up and
make these people laugh and i can't
do that so now this is actually like a
liability a hard job you have to make
people laugh
i mean how do you do that that is so
hard
you make people laugh and cry and all
the things
you stand there in front of them like
it's called a bad
childhood that's what it's called give
one to your daughter and she can also do
this
i said don't go home tonight don't feed
her dinner and completely ignore her
in the chicken coop leave her in the
chicken
coop let her get packed and she too can
grow up to have a
a bird rip her lip off you guys i
haven't told you the story but i had a
bird ripped my lip in half yesterday and
it looks like i have herpes
um which is just a great look around
hillary duff um but uh
but yeah it's just like such a
fascinating um
thing to have to decide i think it's all
your gut and there are times when i'm
like i should keep that to myself
for self-care like i need to keep that
like i talked really openly about
um struggling with eating disorders and
stuff and there are days when i'm like i
wish i hadn't shared all that because
it's taken me so long to move through
them and to not think about food in my
body all day every day and then someone
will come up to me and be like
you i have an eating disorder and you
got me through and i'm like ah it's a
tuesday at 2 30 at the airport and i
don't want to have to think you know
and i'm like yeah i'm like it is what it
is and i'm so grateful that
that affected anybody in a poignant way
because
when i was going through it all i wanted
was to read a book about someone who had
gone through it because i thought i was
the only one but
there are times that i'm like i wish i
hadn't shared that yeah oh me too
oh like when i the time that i ate um my
placenta and
oh yes and then everyone was like might
the quote was like
it was delicious i'm like hold on
dude okay did you eat it in pill form or
did you how did you
eat it not quite in pill form but this
is the whole conversation maybe for the
other podcast you have one of those
you mean the one we cut you mean the one
that hits the cutting room floor the one
that doesn't air
so i had a home birth and my midwives i
call them the witches they're pretty
like hippie dipping
a little like different thinking right
love it and
uh my sister ate her placenta but like
in pill form right
freeze dried kind of thing i don't know
if she she she did it i don't know how
much because it's got some kind of
vitamins in it yeah they say that you
you're it it like stops your body from
like hemorrhaging after you have a baby
like
you re-put it in the other way i know
i mean it feels like that ship has
sailed in terms of
what's going on down there yeah just
stop the bleeding now is like
um anyway but animals do eat their
placenta in the wild
but do they do that because they don't
want predators
yes to remove this yeah to remove the
smell of blood
they say that it gives you all kinds of
like energy and nutrients and helps
balance your hormones and stuff like
that and i'm still completely like
repulsed by it
but they were like we usually like um
the moms will like put a little tiny
piece of it in a smoothie and like lots
of strawberries i know i find a smoothie
that was on the floor of his car
no i hope not but you know what that is
such a good one because when he does bad
things and i get mad at him i like to
torture him like i'll hide his phone
i have no idea like he'll be searching
one time he got sick and i like crank
the heat in our bedroom
like 77. i know she's aggressive but i
think it's so funny
and he cheated on me in my mind and then
i cranked the heat on him and then he
apologizes
this feels like i don't know i'm really
not that scary i think i'm fun to live
with
dm me if you need help dude yeah ready
if you need a place to stay for the
night let me know oh my god like wear
orange on your instagram
if you need help you're just like
gaslighting him turning the heat up and
without telling it sometimes he deserves
it
he's like i have govern but you're
turning the heat up on me no i'm kenny
that is such a wild prank and then
you're like who are you sending that
video to
like i'm chewing my cha
um so you ate your placenta do you think
it worked
no i didn't like eat the whole i didn't
like eat the whole thing as a micro dose
i micro dosed and it was in like a
like when was the last time you ate a
smoothie that was like made with apple
juice
a quarter after never right like yeah
yeah so delicious
like an apple i've had apple juice since
i was like in detention as a kid
i don't think those little apple juices
that are like the little round tree ones
yeah yeah like tree top yeah tree top
yeah
so it was like legit apple juice with
like strawberries and berries and banana
and like i
literally didn't even taste it yeah yeah
and or maybe your placenta just tastes
like sugar
i was like aren't they like purple like
like big like orbeez
okay but let's i know it sounds gross
but it's so badass that a woman can grow
a temporary organ i mean
it's and then you can eat it yourself
you're like also time for you to go
let's go back to talking about your
bloody nipples oh my gosh
oh i don't know i just assumed with the
breastfeeding
oh you felt like you had glass cutting
your nipples oh oh yeah yeah
they never blend you don't like it i
don't even remember the pasties
your nipples have been through a lot you
really you really subject them to a lot
he's gonna kill me
that's my publicist but i didn't tell
him sorry kristen sorry not sorry
um can i i'm just i'm getting dry i love
so okay there's a couple things number
one i know i have to let you go soon
but um number one you changed my life
because i watched a makeup tutorial
video you did like i was like yesterday
i was like doing research and stuff
and you did this thing with your eye
brush where your where it
your eye yes your crease and then you
went down the side of your nose
and i blew my mind that's called the jlo
did you just learn to do this from
growing up on sets with makeup artists
yes
yeah i think after lizzy is like when i
started doing like
and i got into like music so i was like
you know working with like a lot of
different makeup artists and stuff and i
was like
i realized i loved makeup a lot of
people want to know if you getting into
music was your choice
100 my choice i want to be britney
spears
not now you had me on the floor
talking about britney spears the other
day i love her i love her till the day i
die what are we gonna do
you can get her cause you weren't being
mean and
you know like but you were being funny
and the facts were there and i was like
i'm dead right now i mean that and i
were dying
why don't we i just we have to do
something maybe she's
perfectly happy you think would you be
happy and wearing the same pres
peasant top every day for four months
for that arden b peasant top and then
low rise
i mean that that i mean the yellow
stitch
on the denim shorts all figured out but
those hollow little shorts we're living
in right now i know that's a good point
that's a good point she's been in corn
literally
my husband's like honey i'm feeling too
much i can't like
the fires and the election and the world
is we're all gonna die do you try to
protect yourself from that i've started
doing less news
how do you do less news like it it finds
you there's no yeah it's so true
find you can't escape it now you know
the good news for me
is i have my kids so i can literally be
like
they need uh a snack and a water and a
lunch and the two shoes on and you know
what i mean like this is what i'm gonna
need for the day like
here's their schedule here's what you
know like focus on just like the small
things instead of the
the things you can actually solve the
things you can actually control instead
of all the things we can't
what's your take on lying to kids
when it's necessary you have to right
um santa claus easter bunny the whole
thing
oh 100 but i think maybe this is going
to be the year
for a little
but you know what is funny is i think
some kids like to hold on to the
hold on to the magic like because we
have the elf on the shelf
oh yes so thrilled for jimmy to come
back he can't wait and by the way
jimmy's a
shit ton of work there are times where
i'm like in bed and matt and i will be
like
jimmy like one of us will like paper
boxes or who's got to go
move him and like do something epic with
him i feel like they kind of know
like i look back and i'm like i feel
like i knew there wasn't a giant
fairy that took my teeth you know what i
mean like i'm trying to look back
you think luca knows about the tooth
fairy no and i have no
i legit sprinkled some fairy dust on the
dollar bill and he was like it's
shiny like i can't tell if that's
traumatizing to them or not
like we look back and i'm like yeah my
parents lied to me about literally
everything all the time
and i like always wonder what i'm going
to do
you you have it's so fun let them have
the magic they're fun and they'll be
fine
they'll be fine that's the least
traumatic thing you're just like every
kid
okay what is halloween gonna be
what do you have to lie about for
halloween i mean do you already have
costumes lined up i feel like you guys
i don't know i feel like i've had to
burst this bubble a couple times like
halloween might not be the same this
year
well masks they're already in masks it's
kind of halloween is maybe the only
holiday i feel like we can do
that they put this thing out that was
like halloween's cancelled this year
like it's like literally forbidden and
like have you been to a target lately
because there's about 250 freaking
shoppers in there like what's the
difference halloween's outside
i'm not dying for my kid to go take
candy from a random person's house but
like
i don't know come home spray it down
like and it doesn't live on surfaces
right
right like that so i don't know it's so
the kids have had such a rough year
i think that i'll probably let him go
with like a small group i'm going to be
in new york so
would you like people i can do halloween
at my house
you're doing season seven is the season
seven of younger that is so awesome
that's insane
i really wish i hadn't bought an
apartment there it's also i'm going to
say something
that just as someone that has like made
shows before it gets better
every season and that never happened
yeah
i feel like we had a few i forget what
season wasn't my favorite
but it did from there like get better
and better and i was like
that's darren like our writers are great
darren starr 90210 melrose place did you
watch those shows you're too young
oh really i did because i had an older
sister oh yes yeah
so i did and then sex in the city yeah
yeah i've been heard of it
would you let your kids be actors i
think
luca wants to be an actor and i would
but i would make sure that
they would have to go he has to play
your son in a movie yeah
and i would have to be the mentor and
the
biggest inspiration um no i i
would because i have a great life you
know and
i think that i would as someone who grew
up with it i know
how to navigate certain things and i
would not want
anything like handed to him i had to
work my ass off we didn't know anybody
you know when we came here so i would
take him to auditions like
but he would have school would have to
be a priority
and he would have to like prove that to
me because that's the one thing is
sometimes
by the way i've done really well for
myself and i'm sitting in a room
sometimes and i'm like
no idea what they're talking about you
know because i don't i don't have like a
proper education and i learned
so many other valuable things and i
think i have a genuine
interest in things so i'm not completely
lost when people are talking about like
something that happened in history but i
did not have the greatest education no
we i but again everything i learned
isn't even true
you didn't need to go to school at all
it's all it was all wrong
anyway i did know the seven continents i
was really proud of myself for that one
luke is doing that in school right now
i don't i like i don't even want to
embarrass myself and try
i can tell you antarctica south america
north america africa asia
europe is that six wait is canada uh
no that's north america wait asia
australia australia is australia
its own continent yeah oh okay yeah okay
then we did it
yeah we did it how many how many
actresses does it take
to name seven continents okay i'm gonna
do a speed round because i know i have
to let you go
kristen's gonna kill me your children
are gonna kill me and your husband's
gonna kill me
before you do this i've already talked
to connie about soccer please soccer i
just want to confirm
i asked her to check the battery in the
car
but soccer bag needs to be packed yes i
said soccer i said blanket
um thanks my daughter snacks and water
for luca
where do you know where his cleats are i
think there's a ball in the car the red
the red ones
would that have like the sock attaches
yeah yeah yeah okay stars are just like
us
they have to do dumbbells and shin
guards with the tall socks
she runs a tight ship and a pair of
flats for me
i need that's what i'm going to
appreciate to do is to come in your car
so that
then we can get there and all you can
stay and then i'll take connie has to
get her
okay yeah you're going to a park after
this yeah my son has soccer
buddy that is so cute and so what hat do
you are you like a competitive like
get it just kick it uh not during
practice at all but
um during the games yeah you're that
parent
i'm not like screaming but i'm
encouraging yeah
do you yell at other parents no but once
we had a really aggressive mom on the
other team
these are kids it was flag football okay
and
she made a sign that five
bodies had to hold five other bodies
with huge
glitter no letters on them like
saying like broncos or whatever their
team was called and i was like that is
so aggressive and they were so
loud screaming it was a freaking flag
football game for eight-year-olds i was
like
like what is wrong with you and they
were kicking
our ass they were like all way bigger
than our kids blah blah i'm like
all right now you're smoking us put the
damn signs out like yeah yeah slaughter
rule you're winning
you don't need to do all this and who
has the time clearly you don't work
that's fine
we get it you went to joann's fabric i
know yeah spent all day you went
[Laughter]
oh that's right single one kid what
that's a one kid poster
it is okay i just wait so she doesn't
have her car keys
is she a mess like is she is she like on
point or is she like
quickly before i have to go i got
invited to
so i've had to make a whole new group of
friends for banks right like her mom
those mommy friends and i found a really
nice group of friends thank god i'm like
sweating i gotta take this off
so i found so i've been hanging out with
them
we do a couple like singing things in
the backyard like all spaced out and
they have these
she has tiffany tiffany
bitch let me out has these uh lovely
uh her her in-laws invited us to their
beach house in marina del rey just to
like go outside
and hang with the kids and have a beach
day my daughter screamed for 45 minutes
and was the jerk of the party did
wouldn't let me set her down i'm
sweating
and hot like like screaming
and the one time that she did let me set
her down she went and picked up a shovel
and hit her friend in the head with it
and i was like and we're leaving cool
so we're leaving they've like walked to
the beach she's
amazing but she's also a beast so they
walked to the beach and i was like i
just texted her i'm like i had to go i'm
so sorry banks is like a nightmare i
can't do it anymore like it's been 45
minutes i drove to marina del rey that's
like not every day that we go on a
little adventure you ruined this
i'm like talking to a two-year-old i'm
like why did you have to like that why'd
you have to
make i'm in my bathing suit i'm sandy
i'm sweaty i have like three bags
i'm trying to get into their house just
to go down the elevator
because i had to park in there's no
parking in marina del rey right
they have this like cylinder tube thing
that like only one body can fit in
and i'm trying not to get like sand all
over the house and i'm like jamming
myself with my daughter inside this like
cylinder tube
sands like on my butt in a bikini
because i i was just like scrambling to
go okay
i get downstairs the garage is so low i
can't get the door open
and i have to climb through my front
door with my child to crawl
into the back to put her in the freaking
car seat right as the dad comes
downstairs and my butt is just like
like in where the con like the middle
console is and i'm like strapping her
and i'm like i'm basically in tears at
this point right and
and he's like hillary did you need some
help i'm like i hate my child no i'm
fine
like some pants and also elon musk like
you're really like
you screwed this all up
it's like it's too complicated it's
yeah i can never find the little car and
with kids toys how do they not all mix
into the other little cars
also i just need actual buttons to press
i'm not that smart
i can't deal with the thing and the
thing and it's like and then it dies
i am a hot mess i will call her and i'll
be like i'm lost i'm completely lost i
don't know i'm at sunset and
and blair and she's like give me a main
street how am i supposed to wear
parents siri yeah exactly like i see a
chipotle
like i don't know i was in canada with
my family and she called me and was like
i'm in santa monica like
where i don't know how to get home from
here and i was like do you have a
navigation canada sitting on the dock
with my family
my brother can i talk to lauren really
quickly
i can't find my car in the parking lot
like that's happened all the time my son
will be like we lost again
you know what i do oh my god are we lost
again mom this is our car again
i just like a year ago stopped
finding my car in parking lots based on
what color car was next to my car that
was my thing i was like
whitney i feel like it's between a red
car and blue car
no like it's a red jeep and a blue jeep
like it didn't occur to me i'm better
than that i'm better than you i'm better
than that i'm better than you
it didn't occur to me that like the cars
weren't going to stay just for me behind
my car
oh my i'm like this is so weird i parked
next to a blue car why is there a red
car here it's so weird was this prank
like i can be
i'm very ditzy when it comes to that
shit that is
i feel like if i said that to you you'd
be like i have to quit
like that's right draw the line the
bar's low but that's too far
hillary duff has normal problems she has
bullshit too
this feels good to watch yeah this feels
good to just see
her have regular problems last thing
any advice any good advice you've gotten
in your long term sure
just good advice any good advice any
good relationship advice
any good parenting advice
let them cry do you just let them cry it
out when do you when do you go
when do you go when do you go when
they're crying when do you go in
that's my biggest question really if i
hear my dogs barking like i can't handle
it and i'm like i know that when i have
a kid
i'm i'm gonna have to let them cry oh it
depends on the kid
yeah i would probably never have let
luca cry more than
10 minutes 15 minutes thanks
that's fine she just hit someone with a
shovel yeah
i let her cry for 30 minutes before in
the 85 minutes
and the idea is let them stop burn
interesting
yeah she's fine i'm watching her yeah
that's fine but and also second baby and
by the way i'll come in and she'll just
be like hi
and you're like psychopath yeah you just
i thought you were dying that worked
yeah hi
just hold your hands up like get me out
i'm like no what's her birthday am i
allowed to ask yeah her
yeah sorry i don't know put me on the
spot october 25th
and your birthday's coming up my
birthday's coming on beat 33
are you a virgo i'm a libra oh you're
right on the cusp
i'm a libra i am i know so is banks she
decided i had a psychic tell me that she
was like i ca i carried her so low
and the psychic kept being uh the
psychic was like
uh i was like when am i having her come
on isn't she gonna come out early like
i'm so sick of this i hate to be slowed
down i've got like things to do yes
you're very like
on it and so um she was like oh no she's
coming out on her due date and she wants
to be a scorpio and she wants to be born
on a full moon
and she was born on a harvest full moon
on her due date
when it turned to scorpio i'm obsessed
and like she's a real psycho
oh she was like she said she was like i
just i just keep
thinking i call her dancing daughter
she's your dancing daughter and i was
like that's kind of weird
she is always dancing
she does the funniest little dance i'll
show you when this is all over like
she's always in and
i i missed her um i missed her class
today because of you
um well she's going to become a comedian
right this is
going to happen she will be able to pay
her away yeah stop giving me anything
but don't
have too much attention kids need
adversity to be successful you're
welcome my friend we're sending tiffany
was sending me a video and was like she
won't stop dancing i don't know what's
going on like all the other kids are
acting normal and she's covered in
shaving cream and just like shaking her
butt
she's gonna run the world this one
so scary yeah i'm gonna make you do this
again one day
i would come back any time and i'm
obsessed with your eye shadow your
everything i did this for you i love it
i've been trying to wear blue eyeliner
for the entire quarantine and it does
not look anything like that i look
ridiculous oh my god i'm going to send
you this you're going to love it i look
like i'm
a woman in albuquerque going through a
divorce like it looks sad when i do
it you're wrong i've seen it i also love
your
that makeup video you did that just at
home it was so soothing you were so calm
remember the one she just did like in
her
house i'm obsessed with your pink hair
can i tell you
did i copy this from you i had green
hair in the beginning of course i loved
it yeah the murky green
so murky the murky lake what was it
swampy
lake it was something it was the what
yeah this is all
benton benton handled it it was this
took about eight
hours to bleach and then but this is
only like one wash
you're just so brave to bleach your
whole head yeah
but you've committed nothing to lose
than brave but thank you for phrasing it
that way i think it's more has nothing
going on
stop i think it's more unhirable
and can basically do anything no
continuity issues here
um nothing happening no i was actually
shooting a movie when the pandemic
happened
and after like three months i was like
i'm gonna dye my hair pink and then i
was like remember it was like we were
gonna go remember that
month of denial where we thought this
was gonna last till like
i don't know june remember you know yeah
and then finally i just went for it
and then a week afterwards they were
like we're back in production i was like
shit you guys
but don't you love it don't you wait
like feels lovely i know
i love it no one talks to you everyone
thinks you're crazy no one asks you for
advice like it's the best yeah ask you
to watch their kids
like there's just something i started
getting perceived as like a little bit
too responsible and i had to do
something about it
now people don't expect me to like
respond to texts or emails it's great
i need to go back to that life yes you
just have to like find a way to just
like look crazy i basically get
texts every couple days they're like hey
how you doing you okay hang on in there
everything good how's it going girl lots
of girl hey girl
everyone's worried i've had a manic
break and i
have um anything else um
uh uh oh camper no advice
i don't i feel like you've shared so
much already though
you to me are just like a beacon of
wisdom just so you are i'm not joking
yes yes
yes i've always just admired you just
have like a lot of grace and
like we're all oh i thought that was a
lot of grace which i have been feeling a
lot of praise that's the other thing i
want to talk to you about is
your hair something's got to happen i
agree it's i actually have a hair
appointment on monday
you got to have fun that's my advice you
got to have fun you have to
like the other day now more than ever i
gave her the job of cleaning out the
fish tank because i
hate doing it i will do that you will i
will come over and do that
great we have a christmas gekko you can
clean out that and the fish tank no
problem with the chicken coop or the
crust of gekko but when there's lives at
stake
i will truly do that no joke well i'm
obsessed
i used to steal fish from fish tanks
when i was a kid oh me too but i put
them in my pocket and then my mom would
find them and be like um
honey you can't do this anymore i wanted
to keep them i didn't know they were
gonna die in there
i bet you did she was stealing from
bloomingdale's you were we are monsters
but the best you're not going to want to
clean the fish tank because the
like when lauren separated the fish and
had them in the thing i was like
she's like at the sink scrubbing
scrubbing and i'm like i can't believe
how long these guys have lasted for it's
crazy like they're so cute
like ninja tesla sunshine
where's the other one oh no she's like
what i'm like
where's the other one she's like what
are you talking about i'm like just
kidding there was only three and she's
like
no i'm gonna kill you she is sadistic
i'm telling you but also there's one
that has these little
um the catfish cleaner sucker guys yeah
you've got these little like things
whiskers
well i couldn't get them out so i had to
grab them those are hard and spiky by
the way and then they poke you
and she's like no no they're like soft i
was like i have a
i think i have a cut a stab an
hemorrhage from a whisker
from a sharp whisper it's like a barb
but like
they look like a porcupine little
porcupines i literally like grass
and she was like i like to play a lot
play a lot of pranks please
i mean you really do i would like
me singing and stuff oh we need to get a
show out of this
it's like i'd pay to watch this i think
she was filming me
and to pretend that i wouldn't know i
was acting like i was filming banks
like thanks come on get it but really
she's like you are doing something
really darky
and i just post it and then post it and
by the way i was telling you yeah
you need my hair to match that dance
yeah and who walks into the house is
fair game
well i would like to come over anytime i
would like to get pranked because you're
going to get filmed
on instagram the turning the heat up is
still
sends chills down my spine hear you do i
sound crazy i mean
it's diabolical that is because it's a
slow
burn i mean that's a slow you're really
that's not like a one-time prank like a
bucket falls on your head that's like
you're
you're watching someone think they're
going crazy you turned up his
um the ooling the cool the uhler no have
you have you figured out have you found
out about an ooler
no oh my god do you get hot when you
sleep
oh god i i i take sleeping pills
oh god do i get yes i do i wake up
sweaty sometimes yeah okay well
clearly it's not a big enough problem
for you because i feel like either you
have a response where you're like yes i
need that or like
i black myself out i'm unconscious i
have so many other problems before
overheating at this point
don't get the old i'm on don't get the
awareness i make so many sleeping pills
i have no idea
yeah xanax lunesta ambien nyquil like
i'm on such a weird cocktail
like i think before the ula we just need
like betty ford to come in
um i always end these very awkwardly
okay
don't write elephants is always how i
end it don't write elephants
okay because it's mean to the elephant
luca wants to be an elephant activist
and an actor
can i we need to talk yeah okay
the elephants we went to africa for our
honeymoon you just can't get rid of me
this is my truly i will do this all day
i will do this all day because you know
the
the fans are gonna figure out that it
wasn't long enough that i didn't keep
you long enough
so you've done have you done that safari
yet no i'm dying to i'm dying to i was
going to before covet
yeah you were in mozambique right we
went to mozambique after we were in
cougar park
oh yeah sangeeta is that the singular we
didn't see it's in gita but sungita
is amazing i've always wanted to say
that we stayed at lion sands which is
like equally as
amazing they're all kind of near each
other and what happens when you see
the animal in the wild is it just what's
the feeling
the first animal well we saw we saw the
most adorable
like 300 elephants bathing in this like
mud pond on the just from like the
the airport to the hotel i die it's
insane you just
come out of this like gorgeous airport
and you're just in an open air vehicle
and you you're just in like the park
yeah insane
so um that's funny you start to see like
zebras and elephants and you're like
okay move like
after a few days like coyotes like
squirrels at this point
yeah i would say even less rare than a
coyote like it's like a dog you're like
yeah but but they're pretty amazing but
uh the the first like scary one we saw
was a
um i always confuse it it was a cheetah
and i always say leopard they're like
there's no leopards here
yeah like i don't i would conflate those
it was a cheetah and it was coming
around my side of the
the car and i'm like okay this is okay
right this is cool everything's cool
i'm just was like like staying they have
a gun in the car don't they have it they
do but they're like on the front of the
car and the thing is over here by me and
i'm in the back seat
and it's just like starting to like itch
its body on the car
it's in though it's increasing
you smell like placenta this can't be a
good this cannot be
good years ago they're looking okay
um yeah that it was it was really it's
it's insane at first you're totally
freaked out and then also like
rhinos and hippos are super dangerous
super dangerously charged yeah they're
very aggressive
and you can tell or even an elephant if
you see like a bull elephant that means
they're feeling like really feisty if
they're in thrash yeah
yes and don't like mowed you'll just
come up on a bunch of trees that have
been mowed down and they'll know there's
like a bull elephant nearby
and one of them was like standing in the
walkway like not the walkway like the dr
the pathway and was just like rocking
back and forth looking at us
and they're like okay we're just gonna
wait and wait him out he'll get bored
after a while or just a building
it's a building that can sprint yes
yeah this place i work with um paws arc
that i'm gonna
talk to you about afterwards um they are
the elephant enclosure cause i was like
oh let me help you build enclosures they
they took all the um elephants from the
bartoman bailey they shut down barton
bailey and took all the elephants and
they're up north near sacramento and
god that's so cool i know it's so cool
i'm gonna take you um
and cause i'm like yeah let me help you
with an enclosure i work hard i
tour like i've you know i've sold a
couple podcast ads in my day how much
and it's like for a bull elephant
enclosure is something like eight
million
dollars because of the steel has to go i
think it's like 30 feet into the ground
let me get some investors i literally
was like okay i'm gonna just go take a
couple that caulipower pizza campaign i
just passed on oh my god do
i'm gonna have to do that activia ad
after all
um oh my god wait do you ever see people
that like took the thing you turned down
and you're like
turn that one down i think i think all
the ones i get
and the ones
i'm like summer's eve i feel so fresh
thanks hilary
um but uh yeah i mean it's like when a
bull elephant is in thrush they
i mean they can flip cars they can you
know they're so
strong and so they can't put them in the
wild and they can kill other elephants
live right because they've been
i mean you'd have to get them to africa
from here which is just
a fortune but paws is uh one of the few
in the united states um gfas accredited
sanctuaries
which is what we call tolerable
sanctuary tolerable
confinement toler you know so they have
so much space
yeah and they're socialized properly but
yeah the bull the bull elephants are
just so hard to keep in captivity
because it's just they're so fucking
strong
yeah but i've got to take you in in
bangkok the most
magical place no she'll flip over an
elephant but we could take luca oh right
right right
right okay luca okay yes no thanks banks
will be yeah
if we can ever find your keys we will
make this trip how about that
we just call will he'll start the car
for us all right i'll see you guys in
the dm
screaming at me that i didn't ask enough
questions about lizzie mcguire i love
you
but uh she's my real friend and i'm not
gonna ruin my friendship with her to get
you gossip about liz mcguire it'll come
out when it comes out
uh i love you hilary thank you for doing
this what a time
it was so fun thank you for having me i
love you i could literally talk all day
a week